THE AGENDA FOR TODAY TWO BILLS
HAVE BEEN PULLED AT THE AUTHOR'S
REQUEST FIVE BILLS HAVE BEEN
PLACED ON CONSENT.
AND ONE BILL IS A VOTE ONLY ITEM.
AT THIS LEAVES US WITH FIFTEEN
BILLS TO BE PRESENTED TODAY.
ARE THE FOLLOWING BILLS HAVE
BEEN PULLED AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR ATTEND AGENDA ITEM
TEN A. B..
SEVEN THREE FOUR AND AGENDA ITEM
THIRTEEN A. B..
EIGHT TWO SIX AND THE FOLLOWING
AB.
FIVE THREE ONE AGENDA ITEM SEVEN
A. B. SIX ONE TWO AGENDA ITEM
ELEVEN AND A B.. TWO TO ONE ONE
TWO TO ONE I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT --
WE WILL GO AHEAD.
WE HAVE A COURT.
YES [inaudible]
OKAY SO.
LET'S GO AHEAD AND ESTABLISH A
QUORUM SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MADONNA.
A TOTAL HERE STONE.
STONE HERE BELL.
BELL HERE JACKSON PAN WINNER
[inaudible]
WINNER HERE [inaudible] FOR WE
HAVE HERE TODAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AT LEAST RIGHT YES IF.
YOU DON'T MIND COMING UP TO
PRESENT YOUR BILL AND YOUR
WITNESSES YOU HAVE UP TO THREE
MINUTES FOR THEIR PREPARED
STATEMENTS.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO START WHEN
YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
TODAY I COME TO PRESENT EIGHTY
THREE OH SEVEN A GRANTS PROGRAM
WHICH WOULD AWARD FUNDS TO NON
PROFITS OR CONTINUUM OF CARE
ADMINISTRATIVE ENTITIES. TO
PROVIDE SERVICES FOR YOUTH
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
AS YOU MAY KNOW CALIFORNIA HAS
THE HIGHEST RATE OF YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS IN THE NATION WITH
OVER 54% OF THE NATION'S TOTAL
NUMBER OF HOMELESS.
HOMELESS YOUTH RESIDING HERE I
CAT IN CAT ON THE CALIFORNIA
STREETS.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THERE
WERE OVER ONE OVER TWELVE
THOUSAND UNACCOMPANIED.
HOMELESS YOUTH IN CALIFORNIA
WITHOUT WITHOUT A SAFE PLACE TO
CALL HOME.
AND AN ADDITIONAL TWENTY THREE
HUNDRED PARENTING YOUTH
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
ALONGSIDE THEIR CHILDREN.
UNFORTUNATELY THE STATE'S
INVESTMENT IN PROGRAMS TO
SUPPORT YOUNG PEOPLE IN THESE
PREDICAMENTS IS WOEFULLY
INADEQUATE.
WITH ONLY TWENTY OF CALIFORNIA'S
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES HAVING
DIRECT SERVICES FOR YOUTH
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
WITH THE PASSAGE OF AB THREE OH
SEVEN A GRANT PROGRAM TO BE
ADMINISTERED BY THE HOMELESS
COORDINATING AND FINANCING
COUNCIL.
WE WILL BE ABLE TO HELP SUPPORT
SUCCESSFUL LOCAL PROGRAMS TO
PROVIDE APPROPRIATE AND
CULTURALLY INFORMED WRAPAROUND
SERVICES ENHANCING EFFORTS AND
PARTNERSHIPS TO COMBAT YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS.
THERE'S SIMPLY NO REASON THAT
THE WORLD'S FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY SHOULD HAVE SUCH A HUGE
POPULATION OF YOUTH LIVING ON
THE STREETS RATHER THAN
RECEIVING CRITICAL SERVICES.
WELL THE GOVERNOR HAS PROVIDED
SOME FUNDS TO COMBAT HOUSING
ISSUES ACROSS THE STATE.
A DEDICATED FUNDING.
SUPPORT PARTICULARLY FOR YOUTH
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS IS
TRULY WHAT IS NEEDED.
HERE TO TESTIFY WITH ME ON
BEHALF OF THIS MEASURE ARE KIM
LEWIS AND GIOVANE WILKES FROM
CALIFORNIA COALITION. FOR YOUTH.
HI THANK YOU.
WHEN HE WAS DIVINE WORKS AND I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOU?
NOW WATCH OUT TO IMAGINE WHAT IT
FEELS LIKE. TO INDOOR WEEKS OF
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS ON THE
SIDEWALK.
I DON'T HAVE TO IMAGINE BECAUSE
I WAS ONCE HOMELESS AT THE AGE
OF FOURTEEN ON THE SIDEWALK.
TRYING TO MAKE IT THROUGH -- I
WAS UNSAFE AND NOT WELCOMED AT
MY HOME.
WHILE GROWING UP TOO
OVERWHELMING AMOUNTS OF
ADVERSITY BEEN A HOME ISSUE
COULD HAVE BEEN DEBILITATING.
HAD IT NOT BEEN FOR SUPPORT FROM
A SCHOOL PSYCHIATRIST.
AND THE HOMELESS YOUTH SHELTER.
THAT WAS PROVIDED THROUGH THE
CAT THE LOS ANGELES YOU --
NETWORK -- NOW KNOWN AS THE
YOUTH EMPOWERMENT -- YOUTH
EMERGING STRONG.
THERE HAVE SUPPORT OF ADULTS AND
MENTORS ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH
AND PHYSICAL HEALTH CARE.
ACCESS TO EDUCATION SUPPORT BOOT
SHOWER A BED AND A ROOF OVER MY
HEAD. ONE WEEKS ON THE STREETS
ALONE HAVING TO FIND WAYS TO EAT.
STAY CLEAN GET TO SCHOOL STAYING
SAFE AND HOPING FOR AN
UNINTERRUPTED NIGHT OF SLEEP.
BARN DOOR HOMELESSNESS DURING
THANKSGIVING AND CHRISTMAS
HOLIDAYS.
THAT SHOULD NOT BE AN EXPERIENCE
THAT ANYONE SHOULD HAVE TO HAVE
ESPECIALLY OUR YOUTH.
I'VE SEEN A TIME WHILE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS THAT
BEDS DROP IN CENTERS AND YOUTH
SHELTERS DECREASED.
CAPACITY AND EVEN SOME CLOSE
THEIR DOORS.
TODAY I HOPE TO SEE AND LIVE IN
A TIME WHERE YOUTH HOMELESSNESS
IS RARE.
SHORT LIVED NON RECURRING.
AND THAT RESOURCES ARE PROVIDED
TO YOUTH. TO REACH THEIR FULL
POTENTIAL.
YOUR TIME IS MUCH APPRECIATED
AND THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME
SHARE.
HI I'M KIM LEWIS LEGISLATOR
ADVOCATE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YEAR THAN WHEN I
THINK YOU AND YOUR COMMITTEE AND
STAFF FOR THE RIGHT UP.
AND ATTENTION TO THIS ISSUE OF
THE NEEDS OF OUR UNACCOMPANIED
YOUTH EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS --
WE KNOW IT IS A GROWING PROBLEM
BUT WE KNOW WHAT WORKS AND WE
KNOW WHAT'S IN THE BEST INTEREST
AND THE NEEDS OF SUPPORTS AND
SERVICES FOR OUR YOUTH.
AND THAT'S WHAT'S STRUCTURED IN
THIS GRANT PROGRAM IT'S VERY
SIMILAR TO A PROPOSAL YOU SAW
LAST YEAR BEFORE YOUR COMMITTEE
AND WHICH WAS SUPPORTED.
AND WE HOPE THAT WE CAN HAVE
YOUR SUPPORT AGAIN SO WE CAN
HAVE A FRAMEWORK SO WE KNOW
WHERE TO INVEST OUR RESOURCES
GOING FORWARD.
AND HOW WE CAN REALLY AND YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT ABOUT 50%
OF YOUTH -- CHRONICALLY HOMELESS
ADULTS FIRST EXPERIENCED
HOMELESSNESS WHEN THEY WERE YOU.
JUST THINK WHAT IF WE GET AN A
RATING ON DAY.
ONE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY.
ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IF SO PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME.
YOUR AFFILIATION AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL.
NICOLE ORNAMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN BERNADINO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT -- CARES
WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
EMMA GIVES REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND SUPPORT.
MANAGER KEEPS DONOVAN HALF THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT.
TAKE A BREAK -- WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORK CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON JACKI ALONG WITH
INTEL PART IN CALIFORNIA THE
GREASE INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT.
RICHARD RUSSO THE KELSEY
SINICIZATION IN SUPPORT.
TAMMY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA CO SPONSOR
OF THE BILL AND STRONG SUPPORT.
WEST ON ONE HALF OF A SPEAR NET
CHUNKS FOR IT.
DANIEL A CALIFORNIA LANDS OF
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES AND
SUPPORT.
MAR THE GRILL REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT.
SORRY IS AROUND ON BEHALF OF
COUNTY BEAVER HAUL TRACTORS
SUFFICIENT IN SUPPORT.
CHRIS MARTIN AND WE HAVE A HOUSE
IN CALIFORNIA IN THE CORPORATION
FOR SUPPORT OF HOUSING BECAUSE
SPONSORS AND SUPPORT.
BY CAROL WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN SPORT.
JESSE I GET WITH JENNY HOUSES
FROM SUPPORT.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES TO WISH
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL.
WITH THE BELT WE HAVE A MOTION.
ARE THERE -- MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE TO ASK
QUESTIONS OR MAKE CONTACT.
QUICKLY I REALLY WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR -- FOR PICKING THIS
UP AND I'M MOVING THIS FORWARD --
SHE SHE AND I'M HAPPY TO BE A CO
AUTHOR -- THIS IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT WORK AND IT'S GONNA
TAKE TIME AND PERSISTENCE OF
THANK YOU.
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS OKAY SO WE
HAVE A MOTION. TO MOVE THE BILL
[inaudible]
ASSEMBLY.
APPROACH AND LOIS FIRST WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL
[inaudible]
OKAY.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION.
TO IN THE PAST IF YOU PASS THE
SENATE HOUSING -- SENATOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
POTATO I PATADA I STONE.
STONE I BELL.
BELL I JACKSON.
JACKSON KNIGHT PAN.
AND I WINNER [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
FIVE BY.
ZERO SO THE VOTE IS FIVE ZERO
DOUBLE IS OUT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR WOULD LIKE
TO PRESENT ON YOUR NEXT BILL YES
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR ON ITEM
[inaudible] FIFTEEN I WANT TO
BEGIN BY THANKING THE HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE FOR WORKING
WITH MY OFFICE ON THIS BILL.
EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTY FIVE EXPANSE
TRAINING CURRICULUM PROVIDED TO
FOSTER YOUTH RESOURCE FAMILIES
TO INCLUDE INFORMATION ON HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
SPECIFICALLY THE TRAINING
FOCUSES ON RISK FACTORS FOR
COMMERCIAL AND SEXUALLY
EXPLOITATION AND LABOR
TRAFFICKING.
HUMAN TRAFFICKING IS A CRITICAL
ISSUE WHERE IN THE US CHILDREN
AS YOUNG AS ONE YEAR OLD ARE
SUSCEPTIBLE TO EXPLOITATION.
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCE OF DOMESTIC
MINOR SEX TRAFFICKING INDICATES
THAT 7585% OF SURVIVORS WERE IN
FOSTER CARE AT SOME POINT IN
THEIR ADOLESCENCE.
THE FBI ESTIMATES THAT OVER ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND CHILDREN ARE
VICTIMS OF SEX TRAFFICKING
ANNUALLY AND FOSTER YOUTH MAKE
UP 60% OF CHILD SEX TRAFFICKING
VICTIMS.
THE REST TO THIS POPULATION IS
CLEAR BUT CARE GIVERS WERE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THESE YOUTH ARE
NOT PROVIDED.
THE ACCESS TO PROPER TRAINING
AND RESOURCES TO BETTER SUPPORT
THIS POPULATION WE MUST DO
BETTER.
AB EIGHT SIXTY FIVE ADDRESSES
THESE CONCERNS BY PROVIDING
RESOURCE FAMILIES WITH SEVERAL
OPPORTUNITIES TO LEARN MORE
ABOUT THIS POPULATION.
THROUGH THIS EDUCATION RESOURCE
FAMILIES WILL BE PROPERLY
EDUCATED ON HOW TO CARE FOR
THESE YOUTH IN AN APPROPRIATE
AND LOVING MANNER.
HERE TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF
THIS BILL IS JUST TAURUS A
SURVIVOR LEADERSHIP PROGRAM
COORDINATOR AT THE COALITION TO
ABOLISH SLAVERY AND TRAFFICKING.
FROM.
AND A PART OF THE TEAM AT THE
WOMEN'S POLICY INSTITUTE.
OF WAR SPONSORING THIS BILL AND
TELL YOU SIR.
HARVEY AN ADVOCATE AND
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE NATIONAL
SURVIVOR NETWORK POLICY TEAM.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU
SHARE HER TITLE.
AND THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAY IS FOR AT
THE AB.
EIGHT SIXTY FIVE MY NAME IS
TASIA HARVEY AND I AM AN
ADVOCATE HERE TODAY REPRESENTING
RESILIENT PLACES WHICH IS IN LA
SURVIVOR NETWORK WAS SEVENTY SIX
MEMBERS IN THE NATIONAL SURVIVOR
NETWORK WITH THIRTY NINE MEMBERS
IN CALIFORNIA AND THIRTY NINE
MEMBERS IN THE COUNTIES OF
SAMBAR NINETEEN NOW.
LA SAN FRANCISCO AND SACRAMENTO.
I SUPPORT RESOURCE FAMILY
TRAINING BILL BECAUSE I AM A
FORMER FOSTER CHILD WHO IS
TRAFFIC DURING MY TIME IN THE
STATES CUSTODY.
I AM HERE BECAUSE IT IS MY HOPE.
IT IS MY HOPE THAT MY EXPERIENCE
CAN BENEFIT YOU.
CURRENTLY IN CARE.
HAD ALL THE ADULTS IN MY LIFE
WAS SAVED IN MY INNOCENCE WAS
MOST CRITICAL BEEN PROPERLY
TRAINED.
I PROBABLY WOULDN'T BE IN HERE
TESTIFYING IN THE STATE'S
CAPITAL.
I MEAN EVERY ADULT FROM THE
SOCIAL WORKER WHO PLACED ME IN
MY GRANDMOTHER'S CARE.
AND TURNED A BLIND EYE.
AND TURNED OVER [inaudible]
I'M.
SORRY I WASN'T EXPECTING THIS.
THE BLIND EYE WHEN MY
GRANDMOTHER IS IN THE BACK TO
LIVE WITH MY MOTHER.
THE PLACEMENT CENTERS THAT
OPENLY TAUNTED IN A STATEMENT
TIES ME.
AND EVEN THE COUNSELORS AND
THERAPISTS WHO WANTED TO HELP ME
BUT REALLY DIDN'T KNOW I'LL.
PROPER TRAINING CAN RESULT IN
LIES BEING CURVED IN CHANGE FOR
THE BETTER.
AS AN EXTREMELY ON CHILD I WAS
IN THIS I WAS ON THE STREETS
WITH A LOCAL DRILL DRUG DEALER
TEN YEARS MY SENIOR.
WHOM I MET IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD
THIS MAN FORCED ME.
AND LABOR AND SAY.
I'M ASSUMING AND GROOMING FROM A
YOUNG AGE AFTER HE WAS ARRESTED
I MET MY FIRST SEX TRAFFICKER.
SURVIVOR LEADER READ AND
RESEARCHER DR KAREN COUNTRYMAN
BROWSE WYRM STATES THAT DOMESTIC
MINOR SEX TRAFFICKING SURVIVORS
INDICATE PHYSICAL ABUSE
EMOTIONAL ABUSE AND HAVE
EXPERIENCE.
CHILDHOOD SEXUAL MOLESTATION
RAPE AND INCEST AND WHERE IN
FOSTER CARE AT SOME POINT IN
THEIR CHILDHOOD OR ADOLESCENCE.
THIS SAME COURTS THAT TOLD ME AS
A FAB IN TEN YEAR OLD CHILD
TESTIFYING UNDER OATH.
ABOUT THE SEXUAL ACTS FORCED THE
PLAN ME.
THAT THERE WAS NOTHING THAT THEY
CAN DO.
TELL ME I WAS A CRIMINAL.
WHEN I WAS ARRESTED FOR MY FIRST
PROSTITUTION CHARGES AS A MINOR?
HOW AND WHY?
COULD I AND WOULD I INTERESTS.
THEN WITH MY LIVELIHOOD.
PLACEMENT STAFF WILL HOPEFULLY
SAY.
YOU'LL BE BACK HERE AGAIN FOR IT.
AND WHEN YOU'RE EIGHTEEN YOU'RE
GOING TO GRADUATE.
YOU'RE A PROFESSIONAL.
EVEN UP TO MY EIGHTEENTH
BIRTHDAY.
IN AN ATTEMPT TO TURN THINGS
AROUND I MADE IT.
TO THE COUNSELOR THAT I WANTED
TO DO SOMETHING DIFFERENT WITH
MY LIFE.
BUT I REALLY DIDN'T KNOW WHAT TO
DO HAD BEEN SOLD FOR SO LONG.
AND IN RETURN HE FREE.
FREELY ADMITTED HE DIDN'T EVEN
KNOW WHERE TO BEGIN TO HELP ME.
THE CORRELATION BETWEEN
TRAFFICKING IN FOSTER CARE
INVOLVEMENT IS ESTIMATED TO BE.
7085%.
IT IS THE RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
STATE TO DILIGENTLY PROTECT AND
SERVE THESE VULNERABLE YOUTH
TRAFICANT SURVIVORS IN THE
STATE'S CUSTODY CONSIST OF THOSE
PLACED IN FOSTER CARE.
AS A RESULT OF THEIR
VICTIMIZATION.
AS WELL AS THOSE WHO ARE
VICTIMIZED WELL IN FOSTER
PLACEMENT.
IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT MINIMUM
TRAINING STANDARDS ARE IN PLACE
TO KEEP TRAFFIC IN SURVIVOR IS
SAFE. FOR THE DURATION OF THE
TIME THEY ARE IN OUR WARDS OF
THE STATE.
EVERYONE DESERVES A SAFE AND
LOVING HOME THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
HURTADO AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS JUST TORE AS AND I'M
THE SURVIVOR LEADERSHIP PROGRAM
COORDINATOR -- AT THE COALITION
TO ABOLISH SLAVERY AND
TRAFFICKING IN A POLICY FELLOW
OF THE WOMEN'S INSTITUTE A
PROGRAM OF THE WOMEN'S
FOUNDATION OF CALIFORNIA.
WITH THE SUPPORT OF A FAMILY
MEMBER GOMES RAN.
MY COLLEAGUES AND I HAVE
SPONSORED THIS BILL BECAUSE WE
RECOGNIZE THE NEED FOR
COMPREHENSIVE TRAINING TO
ADDRESS THE PERVASIVE
CORRELATION. TO TRAFFICKING AND
SYSTEM INVOLVE THE AS THE CODE
SHARING COORDINATOR OF THE
NATIONAL SURVIVOR NETWORK I HAVE
HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF WORKING
WITH SURVIVORS IN THIS MOVEMENT
WHO ARE JUDGES.
LAWYERS US ADVISERS AND
INTERNATIONAL ADVOCATES WE BRING
TOGETHER A MYRIAD OF EXPERIENCES
AND EXPERTISE TO CREATE CHANGE.
WE ARE WORKING FOR A WORLD
WITHOUT TRAFFICKING THROUGH OUR
HUMAN RIGHTS FOUNDATION WE FOCUS
ON ROUTE ISSUES THAT MAKE PEOPLE
UNIQUELY VULNERABLE TO
TRAFFICKING.
WE ALSO PROVIDE VITAL VOICES AND
PERSPECTIVES THAT ARE OFTEN
EXCLUDED FROM NATIONAL AND
INTERNATIONAL DISCUSSIONS.
AS WELL AS LEADERSHIP.
IN THE MOVEMENT AGAINST HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
THE EDISON HAS OVER THIRTY FIVE
MEMBERS WHO REPRESENT TWENTY
FOUR COUNTRIES AND FORTY STATES
WE HAVE MEMBERS IN FOSTER CARE
REPRESENTING LABOR TRAFFICKING.
SEX TRAFFICKING AND THOSE PLAYS
INTO FOSTER CARE BY THE OFFICE
OF REFUGEE RESETTLEMENT.
THE SCOPE OF THIS NEED IS
ENORMOUS. FOR TWO YEARS I HAVE
BEEN EDUCATING SERVICE PROVIDERS
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND NON PROFIT
PARTNERS ON HEALING CENTER
ENGAGEMENT COMMON FORM CARE.
IDENTIFICATION AND HARM
REDUCTION SKILLS FOR SYSTEM
INVOLVE YOU.
THIS MODEL IS A TWO DAY IN
PERSON TRAINING THAT UTILIZES A
CLINICIAN AND A LIVED EXPERIENCE
EXPERT TO DELIVER A COMBINED
CURRICULUM.
AS PART OF THE LEGISLATIVE
MANDATE WE MUST COLLECT A
VALUATIONS OF EACH TRAINING ONE
EVALUATION STATED I REALLY
LEARNED A LOT ABOUT THE TRAUMA
BASE THOUGHT PROCESS FROM JAZZ.
I FEEL THAT I WILL BE ABLE TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE REACTIVE
AND NON REACTIVE BEHAVIORS OF
IMPACTED YOUTH.
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING IS
ENGAGING THEM AND BUILDING A
POSITIVE RELATIONSHIP THIS
TRAINING HAS SHAPED THE WAY I
WILL APPROACH TEENS IN GENERAL.
HONESTLY I LOVED EVERYTHING
ABOUT IT THE PRESENTERS WERE
AMAZING SO KNOWLEDGEABLE
INSIGHTFUL AND REAL I REALLY
APPRECIATED HEARING FROM THEM IN
THE LAST TWO DAYS.
THE IMMEDIATE FEEDBACK I RECEIVE
FROM COUNTY BASED SERVICE%
PROVIDERS IS THERE HOPE THAT
RESOURCE FAMILIES CAN ACCESS
THIS TRAINING AS WELL.
AS PART OF MY FELLOWSHIP I HAVE
PRIORITIZES LEGISLATION AS A
FIRST STEP IN ADDRESSING
FUNDAMENTAL GAPS TO
UNDERSTANDING THE NEEDS OF THE
MOST VULNERABLE CHILDREN.
THOSE WHO FALL THROUGH THE
CRACKS THE SYSTEM ARE NOT
IDENTIFIED OR WHO ARE WILLFULLY
IGNORED.
AS YOU HEARD FROM MY COLLEAGUE
TASIA HARVEY THE RESULT OF
UNTRAINED RESOURCE FAMILIES AND
PROFESSIONALS IS A HEINOUS ABUSE.
AGAINST OUR YOUTH.
THIS TRAINING IS IMPORTANT FOR
ALL RESOURCE FAMILIES REGARDLESS
OF THEIR AGE AND THEIR CARE.
BECAUSE I WAS.
TOO WHEN IT HAPPENED TO ME.
TOO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THIS BILL COME UP SPEECH YOUR
NAME AND YOUR ORGANIZATION AND
YOUR POSITION TO THE SPELL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MACKENZIE
CHRISTIANSEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
PROGRAM ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
JOHN MCCORMICK -- CHILDREN'S
AUTHOR CALIFORNIA AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
FILES AND ON BEHALF OF PEACE
OVER VIOLENCE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
JESSE AGUILAR JOURNEY HOUSE
STRONG SUPPORT.
DANIEL A CALIFORNIA LINES OF TOM
FAMILY SERVICES AND SUPPORT.
JACKIE ONE WITH AND HELP CARVING
CALIFORNIA THE GRACES TO IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
MY CAR WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
CAN I EARN BERG WITH CALIFORNIA
YOUTH CONNECTION AND SUPPORT.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
DO WE HAVE ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY.
I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE A FAMILY
MEMBER YES I THINK IT'S CLEAR
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY NEEDED I THINK THE
TESTIMONY.
OF THOSE WHO HAVE SUFFERED
THROUGH OUR SYSTEM.
IS THE MOST IMPORTANT TESTIMONY
THAT WE CAN HEAR.
BECAUSE IF SOMETHING LIKE THIS
WERE IN PLACE.
THEY WOULDN'T HAVE HAD TO SUFFER
THROUGH THIS.
AND SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOU RIGHT.
THANK YOU SO WE DO HAVE A MOTION
BY A SENATOR PANNED AND THAT
MOTION IS TO DO PASSED SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS.
SECRETARY PENA PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
PATADA.
REDONDO I STONE.
STONE I BELL.
BELL I JACKSON PAN ALL RIGHT AND
I WINNER.
RIGHT WHEN ARE II [inaudible]
NOW [inaudible] FIVE SO THE VOTE
IS FIVE ZERO WE ARE GOING TO
HAPPEN WE ARE GOING TO PUT THIS --
BILL LONG CALLED TO ALLOW OTHERS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE -- THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING HERE
TODAY AND I ALSO WANTED TO
CLARIFY THAT FOR AID. FOR ITEM
NUMBER THREE A B. -- THREE ZERO
SEVEN THE BOAT IS ACTUALLY.
SIX ZERO VERY GOOD THANK YOU
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THINKING.
THANK YOU SIR.
IN FACT.
ITEM THIRTEEN HAS WITHDRAWN YEAH
[inaudible]
SO WE THE MEMBER ID IN THAT
SENSE.
SO UP NEXT WE HAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIBSON ITEM NUMBER TO A
BE.
ONE SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE COME ON
UP AND FEEL FREE TO PRESENT WHEN
YOU ARE READY.
YOUR WITNESSES MAY HAVE UP TO
THREE MINUTES APART STATEMENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SENATOR AND ALSO TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT -- ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
SEVENTY FIVE WHICH SEEKS TO
MODERN EYES THE THE FOSTER YOUTH
BILL OF RIGHTS BY ADDING RIGHTS
THAT ARE INCLUSIVE.
OF THE YOUTH EXPERIENCE AN
EASILY ACCESSIBLE TO EMPOWER
THEIR DECISION MAKING PROCESS
FALL SO YOU HAVE TO OVERCOME --
IN IN NUMBER BOWL -- A BURDENS
AND HAVING A HIGH RATE OF
UNEMPLOYMENT AND INCARCERATION --
THESE YOU'D HAVE FEW PEOPLE TO
TURN TO THAT CAN HELP THEM
UNDERSTAND THE RESOURCES -- AND
THEIR RIGHTS THEY ARE ENTITLED --
TO IN THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM AND
A LITTLE BIT OF HISTORY IN TWO
THOUSAND AND ONE S. B. EIGHT
NINETY NINE WAS -- AUTHORED BY
SENATOR LIEU OF THIS HOUSE
ESTABLISHING THE BOSS YOU'VE
BILL OF RIGHTS AND REQUIRING THE
SOCIAL WORKERS TO NOTIFY FOSTER
YOUTH OF THOSE RIGHTS.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN I
OFFER TO SIMPLY BUILD ON TEN
SIXTY SEVEN ON WHICH WAS SIGNED
BY GOVERNOR BROWN AND REQUIRE
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. TO CONVENE A WORK
GROUP TO MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS
AND UPDATE PROVISIONS -- TO THE
FOSTER YOUTH BILL OF RIGHTS NOW --
THROUGH THOSE EFFORTS AB ONE
SEVENTY FIVE IS BEFORE THIS
AUGUST BODY TODAY -- WE ARE
MOVING LANGUAGE THAT IS A RESULT
AND THAT IT HAS THE WORKGROUP
HAVE BROUGHT TOGETHER -- AND
IT'S BEEN COUPLED WELL WITH THE
FEEDBACK FROM THE WORKGROUP AT
LONG WITH A D..
S. S..
THIS INCLUDES THE RIGHTS. TO
GROOM AND HYGIENE PRODUCTS FOR
FOSTER YOUTH.
RESPECTING THE CHILD'S CULTURE
AND GENDER IDENTITY AND TO
ACCESS COMPUTER TECHNOLOGY --
THE INTERNET -- THANKS
CONSISTENT WITH CHILDREN -- AND
MUCH OF MATURE AGE AND DEVELOP A
LEVEL -- THAT THOSE INDIVIDUALS
CAN UNDERSTAND -- WITH ME TO
PROVIDE SUPPORTING TESTIMONIES --
IS A REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
TABLE OF CENTRAL UNITED
METHODIST CHURCH WHO WAS SELF
INTRODUCED ALONG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION WHO
ALSO SELF INTRODUCE.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JORDAN SOSA AND SERVE
AS A STATEWIDE POLICY
COORDINATOR FOR CALIFORNIA'S
CONNECTION ALSO FORMER FOSTER
YOU FROM LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND
SERVE AS A C. YC MEMBER THROUGH
THE ORANGE COUNTY CHAPTER.
A FEW THINGS TO KNOW FOR A. B.
ONCE A FIVE FOR THE LAST
EIGHTEEN YEARS CALIFORNIA HAS
MADE MANY STRIDES AND PROGRESS
FOR THE FOSTER YOUTH IN TERMS OF
HOUSING HIGHER EDUCATION
PARTIALLY DUE TO THE WORK THAT
MANY FOLKS IN THE ROOM HAS BEEN
IN THIS COMMITTEE.
AS WELL AS THE CHALLENGES THAT
FOSTER YOUTH FACE EIGHTEEN YEARS
AGO WERE VERY DIFFERENT THOSE
THERE WERE FACE TODAY AND IT'S
CRITICAL THAT OUR PROGRESS AND
PROTECTIONS MATCHES ACCORDINGLY.
I BELIEVE THIS BILL WILL BE ONE
STEPPING STONE CLOSER TO THAT --
ONE THING THEY GAIN THROUGH MY
ADVOCACY WITH CALIFORNIA'S
CONNECTION AND UNDERSTANDING THE
LOCAL ISSUES ARE HAPPENING
WITHIN THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM
WAS A SENSE OF COMMUNITY AND AN
UNDERSTANDING OF MY RIGHTS AS OF
CURRENT AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH.
I DIDN'T KNOW THAT BEING
SEPARATED FROM MY SIBLINGS OR BE
IN TONIGHT TO MAKE PHONE CALLS
TO MY SIBLINGS OR BEING IN
CHARGE TO USE ELECTRONICS IN THE
HOME WAS A VIOLATION OF MY
RIGHTS.
AS AN ORGANIZATION IT IS OUR
VISION TO ADVOCATE FOR ALL FOSS
YOUTH.
AND EMPHASIZE IS THAT ALL YOU
HAVE PEOPLE PUT COULD BE EQUAL
PARTNERS IN CONTRIBUTING TO THE
POLICIES AND THE DECISIONS THEY
MADE IN THEIR DAILY LIVES.
ALL OF YOU THE FOSTER CARE NEED
TO HAVE THEIR NEEDS MET -- I'M
SAYING THIS AS THE STREETS THIS
MAIL IT IS IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE MY PRIVILEGE AND TO
ADVOCATE FOR THE LGBTQ YOUTH WHO
ARE IN FOSTER CARE.
WE BELIEVE THE A B. TWELVE WILL
MAKE THESE DIRECTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA TO INCLUDE THE RIGHTS
THAT GIBSON HAS LISTED.
AND LIKE WE SAID THAT OUR VISION
IS TO HAVE THE RIGHT TO HAVE
THEIR MEETS NET TO SUPPORT TO
HELP THE ENVIRONMENT ADULTS.
WE WILL HEAR OF COMMENTS ON THE
OPPOSITION WHY BUT ONE COMMENT
AND QUOTE THAT MY CIAC MEMBER
MADE THROUGH MY WORK IN
CALIFORNIA WITH CALIFORNIA'S
CONNECTION.
SHE SAID IF TRAUMA COULD BE
PASSED DOWN THROUGHOUT
GENERATIONS.
THEN SO CAN HEALING.
SO MY QUESTION IS WHAT WE WOULD
BE PASSING DOWN TO OUR YOUTH SO
WE PREFERRED ROUTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A A VOTE
FOR THIS LEGISLATION.
AS PART OF AS I HAVE MY BACK TO
THAT PERSON SO I APOLOGIZE
ARRAYED.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LINDA
DO HERE'S TO I'M A COKE PASTOR
OF THE UNITED METHODIST CHURCH
IN SACRAMENTO WE CALL OURSELVES
THE TABLE HI.
IN OUR CHURCH IN SACRAMENTO ARE
FOSTER PARENTS AND FOSTER
CHILDREN.
AS WELL AS PROFESSIONALS IN THE
FOSTERING SYSTEM AND I MYSELF AM
AN ADOPTIVE MOM.
MY FAMILY IS PART OF AN OPEN
ADOPTION AND WE ARE IN -- FULL
LOVING COMMUNITY WITH OUR SON'S
BIRTH MOM AND HIS BIRTH SIBLINGS
AND SHE HERSELF WAS -- PART OF
CALIFORNIA'S FOSTERING SYSTEM.
SOMETIME AGO I SERVED ON A
CONTINUUM OF CARE TEAM IN NAPA
COUNTY WHICH SUPPORTED FOSTER
FAMILIES WHO FOSTER TEENAGERS TO
FIND WAYS.
TO COMMUNICATE AND BUILD TRUST
AND REALLY DIFFICULT AND
CHALLENGING CIRCUMSTANCES.
I KNOW THAT FOSTER CHILDREN
BEGIN BY EXPERIENCING THE TRAUMA
OF SEPARATION FROM THEIR FAMILY
FOR ANY VARIETY OF REASONS.
AND AS A UNITED METHODIST PASTOR
I BELIEVE ALL CHILDREN SHOULD BE
TREATED WITH RESPECT.
AND WITH DIGNITY REGARDLESS OF
THEIR RACE THEIR SEXUAL
ORIENTATION OR GENDER IDENTITY
OR THEIR RELIGIONSO IN ORDER
FOR THE WORK OF OUR FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM TO BE SUCCESSFUL WE NEED
A INTERSECTIONAL APPROACH WHICH
RECOGNIZES THAT BARRIERS AND
EXPERIENCES.
THE CHILDREN HAVE AROUND RACE
SEXUAL ORIENTATION GENDER
IDENTITY AND RELIGION MAY CREATE
CHALLENGES FOR OUR PROFESSIONAL
WORKERS.
AND THOSE WHO ARE TRYING TO BE
CALM OR BE FOSTER PARENTS.
SO AS A PASTOR SUPPORTING A LOT
OF OF FOSTER PARENTS I BELIEVE
IT IS THE RESPONSIBILITY OF A
FOSTER PARENT TO PROVIDE THE
ABSOLUTE BEST.
LOVING AND STABLE ENVIRONMENT
FOR THEIR FOSTER CHILD OR
CHILDREN REGARDLESS OF WHO THE
CHILD IDENTIFIES AS OR WHAT THEY
WOULD LIKE TO BE CALLED I ALSO
UNDERSTAND THAT THE WORK TOWARD
FULL INCLUSION FOR FOSTER USE IS.
HARD WORK IN ITS VARIED AND IT'S
COMPLEX -- THEREFORE I AM IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE SEVENTY FIVE
WHICH SEEKS TO MODERNIZE THE
FOSTERED USE.
BILL F RIGHTS FOR ALL OF US SO
THAT IT ADDRESSES CURRENT
CULTURAL COMPETENCIES.
AND AMONG THOSE ARE LIFTING UP
THE RIGHTS OF NATIVE AMERICAN
CHILDREN UNDER OUR INDIAN CHILD
WELFARE ACT. TO RECEIVE GROOMING
AND HYGIENE PRODUCTS.
WHICH THE WHOLE WORLD SHOULD
WANT TEENAGERS TO ALWAYS HAVE
REGARDLESS.
REGARDLESS OF THEIR ORIENTATION
AND GENDER IDENTITY ANDTO
ATTEND A CULTURAL ACTIVITIES
CONSISTENT.
WITH THEIR IDENTITY AS WELL AS
FINALLY TO BE REFERRED TO BY
THEIR PREFERRED NAME AND THEIR
GENDER PRONOUNS.
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU --
HEARING ME TODAY THANK YOU.
I WOULD HAVE SEND YOUR
SUBCOMMITTEES AMENDMENTS TO THIS
BILL.
I TRIED WITH INTREPID I IT
[inaudible] ONE MOMENT -- YES.
ABSOLUTELY WE DO TAKE REMEMBERS
ALL RIGHT WELL THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
SO WE'LL GO AHEAD AT THIS POINT
WE'LL TAKE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL -- IF YOU CAN
PLEASE COME UP AT A STATE YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION ON THIS BALL BACK A
KRAMER MATTER HE'S A YEAR
CALIFORNIA HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KATHY HALL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PTA IN SUPPORT.
THERE MICHAEL GASTON ON BEHALF
OF YOU FORWARD IN STRONG SUPPORT.
TAKE A BREAK OR NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORK
OFFERING CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
CHRIS PARALYZE RETURNS RIGHT
TRANSPORT.
HELLO WESTERLY MAY HAVE A SPIRIT
AND SUPPORT.
DANIEL A CALIFORNIA LINES OF
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES AND
SUPPORT.
JUST BEEN HERE IS CALIFORNIA
YOU'VE CONNECTION IN SUPPORT.
CAN AREN'T VERY CALIFORNIA'S
CONNECTION AND FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH IN SUPPORT.
THE SERVER NET AS FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH AND SUPPORT.
JUST CHECK YOUR JOURNEY HOUSE IN
SUPPORT.
GENEREX ROAD CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE
OF CARE GIVERS AND SUPPORT.
CHRISTINA PARKER FROM FIVE FEET
AT THE PORT.
GREAT.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES AND
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
PLEASE COME UP
.
IT JUST THREE MINUTES GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU DUMB.
MY NAME'S GREG BIRDS -- CHAIR
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME --
I WORK FOR THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY
COUNCIL.
AND I JUST WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT
SOME SOME OF THE CONCERNS WITH
JUST SOME OF THESE RIGHTS.
THEY'RE BEING ESTABLISHED THAT I
THINK IS WORTH A DISCUSSION --
YOU KNOW AS FAR AS YOUR SYSTEM
IS SET UP TO PROTECT KIDS FROM
BEING EXPLOITED -- INTO INSURE
THEIR SAFETY SO.
I THINK THE QUESTION WE NEED TO
ASK IS DO ALL THESE RIGHTS
ACTUALLY KEEP KIDS SAFE.
SO HERE'S SOME OF THE ONES THAT --
WE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT -- OF THE
RIGHTS TO THE INTERNET --
DOESN'T SEEM TO HAVE AN AGE ON
HERE I KNOW MY LIVER NEAR OLD
SON.
DOESN'T HAVE UNLIMITED RIGHTS
THE INTERNET'S -- SOME CONCERN
ABOUT THAT HOUSE AT THE FIND --
HERE'S ANOTHER THING I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT TO MAKE.
SEND RECEIVE CONFIDENTIAL PHONE
CALLS AND LIKE TRYING TO
COMMUNICATIONS.
I'M ASSUMING THIS MEANS EMAILS
TEXTING AND SNAIL MAIL.
TO OKAY MY ELEVEN YOUR WHOLE
DOES NOT HAVE THE RIGHT TO HAVE
CONFIDENTIAL PHONE CALLS.
BECAUSE I'M OUT TO PROTECT HIM
RIGHT AND IT AND LIVE TWO GIRLS
AS WELL AND SO I'M INVOLVED IN
THEIR LIVES I WANNA MAKE SURE
ADULTS ARE NOT.
ENOUGH TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THEM --
OTHER THE NEXT ONE OF THE RIGHT
AT ANY AGE TO GET ACCESS TO
CONTRACEPTION.
ABORTION SEXUAL SOLD HEALTH CARE.
WITHOUT THE KNOWLEDGE OR CONSENT
OF ANY ADULT -- I CANNOT IMAGINE
WHY THAT WOULD.
BE IN THE BEST DIFFERENCE BEST
INTEREST OF FOSTER KIDS -- L.
ANOTHER ONE THE RIGHT TO BE FREE
FROM UNREASONABLE SEARCHES OF
PERSONAL BELONGINGS.
OKAY WHEN I I USED TO WORK FOR
SENATOR WALTERS DOWN IN ORANGE
COUNTY AND ONE OF THE THINGS I
WAS IN CHARGE OF WAS.
A SEX TRAFFICKING AND SO I GOT A
TOUR OF THE ORANGE WOULD GROUP
HOME AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT --
THEY TOLD US DOWN THERE IS IS
THAT.
JUST SOMETHING WE JUST HEARD THE
LAST HEARING THAT FOSTER KIDS
ARE VERY VULNERABLE TO BEING
TRAFFICKED.
AND THEY WOULD ACTUALLY DO THE
TRAFFICKERS WAS ACTUALLY RECRUIT
KIDS INTO TRAFFICKING AND THEN
THEY WOULD SEND THEM BACK INTO
THE HOME TO RECRUIT THE OTHER
KIDS -- AND WE'LL DO KNOWING
THESE NEW RIGHTS I THINK THIS IS
THE TRAFFICKERS ARE GONNA LOVE
THIS -- BECAUSE THEY'LL BE ABLE
TO COMMUNICATE WITH KIDS AND THE
FOSTER CARE PARENTS AND
OVERSEERS WILL BE ABLE TO SEE
THAT ANYTHING IS HAPPENING --
ANOTHER RIGHT THAT'S ESTABLISHED
FOSTER CARE PARENTS CAN'T
THREATENED TO CALL POLICE
[inaudible]
I'M NOT.
LOVE TO HAVE THAT EXPLAIN TO ME --
AND THEN ALSO THE RIGHT -- THIS
BEING ESTABLISHED TO BE REFERRED
TO BY THE PREFERRED NAME IN
PRONOUN NO MATTER WHAT THE AGE
OF THE CHILD -- WITH OUR
ORGANIZATION A LOT OF FOLKS --
WITH RELIGIOUS BACKGROUND WITH
VERY TRADITIONAL VIEWS ON GENDER
AND SEXUALITY AND A LOT OF THEM
WERE APPALLED FOSTER CARE.
AND WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IS BY
FORCING.
ARE THESE PARENTS TO A FIRM --
BELIEVES THAT THEY DON'T BELIEVE
IN -- THAT'S GOING TO PUSH THOSE
KIDS OUT OF FOSTER CARE THAT NO
THOSE KIDS WITH THE PARENTS OF
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM SO. FOR
THOSE EASONS -- WERE IN
OPPOSITION THANKS.
SURE THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND IT CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
THE GENERAL FOR A RAISING OF THE
SAME QUESTIONS AS HE DID AND THE
ASSEMBLY -- HUMAN SERVICES --
LET ME JUST SIMPLY SAY WHAT
WE'RE DOING IS -- FOR INSTANCE --
THROUGH A MEMBER TODD GLORIA HAD
ALREADY -- MADE -- CODIFIED --
LAW IN -- IN BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WITH ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY ONE AND NINETEEN
THEY TALKED ABOUT GENDER
AFFIRMING CARE.
A LOT OF THE BILLS THAT -- THE
GERMAN SPOKE ABOUT WE BRING IT
TOGETHER.
AND WE'RE PUTTING IT INTO THE
POLICY THE BILL OF RIGHTS IS A
LOSS THESE ARE ALREADY LAWS THAT
THESE YOU ALREADY HAVE.
BUT THEIR PLACE IN DIFFERENT
PLACES WHAT WE'RE ATTEMPTING TO
DO IS PLACE THIS INTO THE BALL
TO YOU BILL OF RIGHTS WITH DS
ASK HAS ALREADY -- ACQUIESCE IN
TERMS OF WORKING WITH THIS IN
TERMS OF MAKING THIS BILL --
BETTER -- WHEN IT COMES -- TO
YOU KNOW.
NOT HAVING THE ABILITY TO CALL
THE POLICE CERTAINLY A PARENT
HAS THE ABILITY IN TERMS OF
CALLING THE POLICE SPECIALLY IF
IN FACT SOMEONE'S LIFE ISN'T IN
DANGER -- RAISE THE QUESTION IN
TERMS OF WHETHER OR NOT A CHILD --
NAMES PRO NOW RIGHT WELL.
YOU SHOULD BE WANTED TO IF
YOU'RE BRINGING A CHILD IN AS A
FOSTER YOU INTO YOUR HOME -- THE
GOAL IS TO PROVIDE A STRUCTURE
AS A GOAL THERE IS ALSO PROVIDE --
LOVING GUIDANCE -- AT THAT TIME
I WANT TO BE CALLED BY THEIR PRO
NOW THEN YOU SHOULD DO JUST THAT
DO YOU WANT TO FURTHER
STIGMATIZE -- OUR CHILDREN AND
TRAUMATIZED WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE MOST VULNERABLE YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO WERE IN FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
TODAY AND WE WANT TO TRY TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO LOVE THEM.
I'M JUST SHOW THEM LOVE -- NOT
PERSECUTE THEM -- NOT FURTHER
DISENFRANCHISE THEM -- NOT TRY
TO MAKE THEM TO BE SOMETHING
THEY'RE NOT -- THEY'RE NOT
ALREADY RIGHT AND SO THIS BILL
SEEKS.
TO ALLOW ON THE FALSE TEETH BILL
OF RIGHTS TO HAVE CERTAIN RIGHTS
DON'T WE WANT KIDS TO HAVE A
ACCESS TO HYGIENE PRODUCTS AND
AND GROOMING.
WHY WE WERE WE WILL PUT THIS IN
HERE?
WE WOULD HAVE TO PUT THIS IN
HERE IF IT WAS ALREADY BEING
DONE.
AND IT'S NOT BEING DONE THAT'S
WHY WE PUT IT INTO LAW THE
MAKING SURE THESE FOSTER YOU
UNDERSTAND THEIR RIGHTS.
UNDER THE FOSTER YOUTH BILL OF
RIGHTS AND SO SENATORS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHAT I VOTE.
FOR A B..
ONE SEVENTY FIVE WHAT EFFECT OF
OUR HERE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL.
DO WE HAVE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
PLEASE COME UP STATE YOUR NAME
AND ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION.
SUPPORT THE SUPPORT.
STEVE ASHTON EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF CASA STAN ASSAULTS COUNTY AND
I WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
JOIN THE CORRECT CHILDREN'S LAW
CENTER OF CALIFORNIA IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
DO YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
AT SENATOR PENN.
I THANK YOU SUMMER GIBSON AND I
APPRECIATE -- WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO ACCOMPLISH WITH THE BELL AND --
ALSO I THINK MANY OF THE
ADDITIONAL RATES THAT ARE I HEAR
THE CHAINS STANDARD.
COMES CAME FROM A STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS CORRECT RIGHT YEAH.
I THINK THERE ARE VERY IMPORTANT
IF YOU JUST WANT TO CLARIFY --
SO ONE OF THOSE IN AND I GUES
IT DOES TOUCH A LITTLE BIT ON
SERVE -- THIS APPLIES TO ALL
FOSTER YOUTH THOUGH SO THEY
SPEND THE AGE RANGE -- SO IN
GENERAL I WOULD AGREE THAT --
THAT YOU KNOW PROBABLY AT AND
OUR LESSON OR SOMEONE -- WITH
THE ONES THAT USE YOUR OWN
HEALTHCARE PROVIDER FOR YOUR
MEDICAL DENTAL CENTER AND IN IN
IN PRINCIPLE I THINK THAT MAKES
SO A LOT OF SENSE -- BUT AT SOME
POINT IN TERMS OF THE AGE RANGE
YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE.
TALKING ABOUT.
MAYBE EVEN A TWELVE YEAR OLD OR
A FOURTEEN YEAR OLD.
WE THOUGHT ABOUT FIVE OR SIX
YEAR OLDER THREE YEAR OLD AND
JUST WANTED TO KNOW HOW THESE
HOW DO YOU SEE THIS
OPERATIONALIZE AND EXACTLY WHAT
IS RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES. TO
SEE THAT HOW HOW HOW IS THAT
RIGHT FORCED FOR VERTICALLY A
YEAH AT A VERY YOUNG CHILD.
TO PERHAPS IS USUALLY NOT IN YOU
KNOW MAY NOT NECESSARILY BE AT
THE AGE IN WHICH WE DON'T EXPECT
TO MAKE THOSE CUTS THAT CAN
DECISION I JUST WANT TO FIGURE
OUT HOW THAT WATER SERVING WITH
THE WOODEN AND THE THING IS A
WORLD.
YOU SOCIAL WORKERS WILL ALSO
CONTINUE TO PLAY A ROLE RIGHT IN
THIS PROCESS TO MAKE SURE THAT
FOSTER YOUTH HAVE.
ADEQUATE CARE AND ACCESS TO THE
ADEQUATE CARE -- WHEN IT COMES
DOWN TO HELP KINDS OF DECISION
MAKING ALONG WITH THE FOSTER
CARE YEAH I?
GUESS THAT -- IS THIS -- AT THIS
BILL MOVES FORWARD AND BACK
CERTAINLY I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT AND IS FORD -- I THINK
MAYBE SHOULD LOOK AT SOMEBODY'S
AND THINK ABOUT PUTTING SOME
PHRASES ABOUT YOU KNOW.
A RELATION TO THEIR
DEVELOPMENTAL YOU KNOW CAPACITY
RIGHT I I JUST.
I JUST WANT TO BE SURE THAT AS
WE AS AS WE MOVE THIS YEAH.
HOPEFULLY THIS BILL BECOMES LAW
AND THOUGH EXACTLY HOW THEREFORE
WHAT IS THE RISK CLEARLY THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE COUNTY YOU
KNOW.
THE OFFICE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
THE WHAT THE STATE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM THAT BUT TO YOUR PARENTS
SO THAT THEIR SO THAT THERE
ISN'T -- AND IT DOES SO THERE'S
MORE CLARITY ABOUT WHO'S
RESPONSIBLE FOR WHAT I THINK WE
WANT TO EMPOWER FOSTER YOUTH.
BUT WE ALSO RECOGNIZING.
THE AGE SPAN IN WHICH SOMEONE'S
IN FOSTER CARE ALL THE WAY UP TO
TWENTY ONE THANKS CENTRE BELL --
THAT WE WANT TO BE SURE THAT THE
THAT THE THAT WE'RE RESPECTING
YOUR DEVELOPMENTAL STAGE AND OF
COURSE CERTAINLY A FOSTER YOUTH
IS IN THEIR LATE TEENS OR
CERTAINLY BY TENDER EIGHTEEN AND
TWENTY ONE THEY SHOULD BE.
YEAH CALLING SHOTS AND MAKING
DECISIONS BUT WE ALSO HAVE A
YOUNG FOSTER CHILDREN WHO.
WHICH IS ON A WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN IF IT'S IN THE FOSTER THE
END THIS -- BILL OF RIGHTS AND
SO WHAT IS WHAT IS
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE FOSTER
YOUTH VERSES THE FOSTER PARENT
VERSUS THE FOSTER THAT THE
SOCIAL WORKER WHO WORKS FOR THE
POINT WELL TAKEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WITH
THAT I'D BE HAPPY TO MOVE THE
BILL THANK YOU [inaudible]
SO WE RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I
BOUGHT.
RIGHT SO THAT MOTION IS WAS MADE
BY SENATOR PAN AND THE MOTION IS
TO DO PASSIVE AS AMENDED -- TO
SENATE JUDICIARY A SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL.
MADONNA I RETIRED A HIGH STONE.
STONE NO BELL.
JACKSON.
PAN RIGHT HAND I WINNER.
WINNER I
THREE ONE THREE NUMBER
FIVE EIGHT THREE FOUR THREE NINE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE.
SOME REMEMBER SOME PLEASE FEEL
READY TO THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS SO A YEAR AGO WHEN
IN DOING WORK AROUND.
DETERMINATION OF JUVENILE
COMPETENCY ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE MISSED IN CREATING THE
STATUTE WAS THAT THE FACT THAT.
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS ARE NOT
APPROPRIATE PLACEMENTS FOR KIDS
AS WE ARE TRYING TO ESTABLISH
COMPETENCY THAT WAS AN OMISSION
IN LAST YEAR'S BILL ALL THIS
DOES IS REMOVED TO A METAL
CENTERS AS A PLACEMENT WHICH
THEY SHOULDN'T BE.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IBM [inaudible]
OKAY.
WE HAVE ANY -- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES AND THE
PROPOSED TO THIS BOOK
[inaudible]
WITH.
PLEASE COME UP PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME -- ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION ON THIS BILL.
KATHY ALL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PTA AND SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
DO WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT.
ANY ADDITIONAL OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL OR ANY OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
THREE NINE OKAY.
I DO HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YOU HAVE A MOTION AT IT SHOULD
YOU PASS THE SENATE FOR WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I ASKED YOU
HAVE A SO THE MOTION IS TO DO
PASS TO CENTER FOR SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
RIHANNA.
I TITLE I STONE.
STONE HI BEL.
JACKSON TENN WINNER.
WINNER HI THREE ZERO SEVEN THREE
ZERO AND WE WILL GO AHEAD AND
PUT THIS PHONE CALL.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SO.
UP NEXT IS ITEM NUMBER EIGHT A
B. SIX TO SEVEN BASED ON THE
NUMBER OF PATIENTS.
PLEASE COME ON UP AND FEEL FREE
TO PRINT.
FEEL FREE TO PRESENT WHENEVER
YOU ALREADY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
EIGHTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN REQUIRES
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES TO IDENTIFY REGIONAL
CENTERS ARE IN NEED OF SATELLITE
OFFICES.
AND TO CONSULT WITH EACH
IDENTIFIED REGIONAL CENTER TO
DETERMINE THE LOCATION OF A
SATELLITE OFFICE WERE OFFICES.
EIGHTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN WILL
IDENTIFY THOSE AREAS MOST IN
NEED OF ONE OR MORE ADDITIONAL
REGIONAL CENTERS OFFICES.
SO THAT EVERY PERSON WITH ADD
CAN BE PROVIDED ADEQUATE
SERVICES.
THIS BILL HAS HAD UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT AND RESPECT AS RIVALS
WITH ME.
TODAY I HAVE. TO TESTIFY ERROR
OCCURS FROM DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ERIC HARRIS AND I AM
HERE ON BEHALF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA AND WE SUPPORT A B..
SIX TWENTY SEVEN DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IS A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION THAT ADVANCES AND
PROTECTS THE RIGHTS.
OF CALIFORNIANS WITH
DISABILITIES.
AB SIX TWENTY SEVEN WOULD
REQUIRE THE DIRECTOR OF
DEVELOPMENT SERVICES TO IDENTIFY
REGIONAL CENTERS THAT WOULD NEED
SATELLITE OFFICES IN RURAL
CATCHING CATCHMENT AREAS.
SATELLITE OFFICES WOULD GIVE
PATIENTS WHO LIVE IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES -- FAR FROM REGIONAL
CENTERS AND OPPORTUNITY TO
RECEIVE SERVICES AND ANY OTHER
SUPPORT THAT THEY MIGHT NEED.
THE STAFF AT REGIONAL CENTERS NO
WHEN THERE IS A NEED FOR
SATELLITE OFFICES IN THEIR AREA.
THE SATELLITE OFFICES CAN BE
EXTREMELY HELPFUL FOR PEOPLE
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
AND CAN OFTEN BE CRUCIAL FOR
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES LIVING
IN RURAL COMMUNITIES.
AS WE ALL KNOW TECHNOLOGY HAS
HELPED MANY PEOPLE GET SERVICES
ADVICE.
OR CARE FOR THEMSELVES.
MOST PEOPLE WHO HAVE ACCESS TO
THE INTERNET CAN GET INFORMATION
ABOUT THEIR MEDICAL CONDITIONS
AND MEDICATIONS.
I NEED A TRUCK AND MY NEED TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES THAT
THEY'RE HAVING MOVING FORWARD WE
HOPE [inaudible]
THAT -- THE SERVICES SUCH AS
ZOOM SCRIBE AND OTHER
INTERACTIVE COMMUNICATIONS CAN
BE CONSIDERED -- TO HELP THESE
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN NEED OF
SERVICES THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY WE URGE OUR VOTE ON EIGHTY
SIX TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY HERE
TODAY.
I DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THE SPELL.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL.
THIS BILL DOES HAVE ABIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
FILTER.
IT'S OKAY I THINK WE HAVE A
MOTION -- YES DO WE HAVE YOUR
COMMENTS GO AHEAD THANK YOU
SENATOR FRASIER I I APPRECIATE
THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE BRINGING THIS
FORWARD -- THE INLAND REGIONAL
CENTER IS -- IF YOU KNOW WHAT
TAKES CARE FOR SALMON DINO IN.
RIVERSIDE COUNTY RECYCLING IS
THE SIZE OF THE STATE OF NEW
JERSEY.
AND RIVERSIDE IN DECEMBER DINO
COUNTY -- IS LARGER THAN NINE OF
THE SMALLEST STATES SO THAT A
GOOD IDEA HOW FAR PEOPLE HAVE TO
TRAVEL WE GOT A YOUNG KID WITH
WITH AUTISM CEREBRAL PALSY.
IT JUST MAKES IT SO DIFFICULT
AND BASICALLY BECOMES HEALTH
CARE RATIONING WHEN YOU CONSIDER
THE TRAFFIC AND THE EXPENSE OF
GETTING THERE SO THIS IS REALLY.
A VERY IMPORTANT BILL TO MY
DISTRICT AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
BRINGING IT FORWARD.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY -- WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MENTOR A AS
SENATOR SO DID MENTION WE HAD
DONE A I'M THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND WE DID A HEARING COACHELLA
AND THAT RESONATED FROM THE HIS
CONSTITUENTS IN THAT AREA THAT
THEY JUST HAD NOT HAD ACCESS.
IN VERY LIMITED TRANSPORTATION
OPTIONS TO GET TO THE REASONS IN
SEPTEMBER AND YOU KNOW IF THEY
COULD GET IN BECAUSE OF THE
TERRORIST ATTACK.
NOW IF YOU HAVE TO HAVE AN
APPOINTMENT SO IT'S VERY VERY
ONEROUS TO GET TO THESE PLACES.
AND THIS IS OF COURSE BETTER
ACCESS AND YOU KNOW THIS
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS EVERY
BENEFIT THEY CAN GET THAT IT'S
PROVIDED TO THEM I WENT ON A
REQUEST THAT I COULD BE ADDED AS
A CO AUTHOR AND LIKE TO SHOW
THEM A CHAMPION WITH YOUR PARK
AND ANOTHERCOUNTIES OF THE THIS.
LETTER SIGN.
MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
I RESPECT THIS RIGHT.
Q. I HAVE WITH THE MOTION OF WAS
MADE BY SENATOR PANTS AND THE
MOTION IS TO TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS.
US SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL -- TADA I A TITLE I STONE.
STONE I BELL.
JACKSON PAN.
PAN I WINNER.
WINNER I FOUR ZERO SO THE BOAT
AS FOUR ZERO WE WILL GO AHEAD
AND PUT THIS BILL LONG CALL.
OTHER SICK AFTER BUSH THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
TO SO AT THIS MOMENT -- WE WILL
GO AHEAD AND TAKE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR MOVED [inaudible]
GREAT.
US SECRETARY PLEASE [inaudible]
OKAY SORRY.
SO THAT'S A G. AGENDA ITEM
NUMBER FOUR A B. THREE THREE
SEVEN AGENDA ITEM SIX A. B..
FIVE THREE ONE AGENDA ITEM.
SEVEN EIGHTY SIX ONE TWO WHICH
IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS SORRY AGENDA ITEM
ELEVEN A. B. SEVEN FOUR EIGHT
GIBSON DUE PROCESS SENATE
JUDICIARY AND A GOOD ITEM
NINETEEN EIGHTY BETWEEN. ONE TWO
TWO ONE AND THEN MOTIONS TO TO
PASS ON THE FLOOR. EIGHTY THREE
THREE SEVEN COURTS OVER THE
MOTION IS THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS AN A. B. FIVE
THIRTY ONE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO JUDICIARY.
IN ADDITION -- TITLE.
I RETIRED A HIGH STONE RIGHT
STONE I DON'T [inaudible]
JACKSON.
JACKSON I PAN HI AM I WINNER.
WINNER I FIVE IT'S KIND.
ALSO THE BOW IS FIVE ZERO AND
THE CONTENT CALENDARS ON CALL.
OKAY NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER. TWELVE EIGHT EIGHT ZERO
SEVEN WELCOME THANK YOU PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO PRESENT FOR YOU
ALREADY AND I WOULDN'T.
HAVE TO THREE MINUTES TO PRESENT
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
HAPPY TO BE HERE AND I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
YOUR HELP ON THE COMMITTEE
MENACE I HAPPILY ACCEPT THEM I
THINK THEY'RE GOOD.
CHANGE TO THE BELL AND WILL MAKE
IT EVEN STRONGER.
I'M JAN PRESENTING ON AVIATOR
SEVEN WHICH CREATES EQUITY FOR
LOW INCOME STUDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES BY REMOVING INCOME
EXCLUSIONS WHICH PENALIZED
FAMILIES ON CAL WORKS FOR A
STUDENT SCHOLARSHIP.
RENTAL ASSISTANCE IN ANY
TRANSFERS OF MONEY FROM AN
EDUCATION ACCOUNT TO ANOTHER
ACCOUNT.
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL WOULD ALSO
EXEMPT CENSUS RELATED INCOME
FROM EITHER GOVERNMENTAL OR NON
PROFIT AGENCY TO ENCOURAGE
CENSUS PARTICIPATION IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
GIVEN THE ECONOMY RIGHT NOW IN
CALIFORNIA WE KNOW THAT IT MIGHT
BE HARD TO GET CENSUS WORKERS
AND WE DON'T WANT THEM TO HAVE
TO CHOOSE BETWEEN THEIR TOWERS
BENEFITS IN HELPING US GET TO
COMPLETE COUNT.
THE CALORIES PROGRAM SERVES
NEARLY FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND LOW
INCOME FAMILIES BY PROVIDING
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE FOR HOUSING
FOOD AND OTHER NECESSARY
EXPENSES.
OF THESE FAMILIES TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY EIGHT THOUSAND
RECIPIENTS ARE STILL LIVING IN
DEEP POVERTY.
THE BILL EXPANDS LIST OF ITEMS
EXEMPTED FROM FEDERATION AS
INCOME WHICH REMOTE SMART SAVING
HABITS WHILE HELPING TO BREAK
THE CYCLE OF POVERTY WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT STUDENTS CAN BOTH
GO TO COLLEGE AND EAT.
WITH ME TODAY IS JUST GIVE OUR
FLOW FROM THE WESTERN CENTER
LINE POVERTY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE TO ASK ABOUT THE
WITH WESTERN CENTER A LAN PARTY
WE ARE SPONSORING SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL REALLY PROUD. TO BE
OFFERING YOU -- THAT PROPOSALS
IN FRONT OF YOU WHICH ADDRESS
CONCERNS THAT W RECEIVE THROUGH
LEGAL SERVICES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- WITH
PEOPLE WHO ARE STRUGGLING.
TO TO KIND OF PLOW THEIR OWN
PATH OUT OF POVERTY BUT TO DO SO
WITH RULES I CAN BE MORE.
RESTRICTIVE RESTRICTIVE -- FOR
THEM TO BENEFIT FROM SOME OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT WE'RE INVESTING IN
HERE IN CALIFORNIA SUCH AS
SENSES THAT REACH SO -- BOTH FOR
THE REASONS OF HELPING FAMILIES.
IMPACTED BY POVERTY AND TRYING
TO BUILD THEIR WAY OUT BUT ALSO --
TO ADDRESS SINCE THE THUNDER
COUNTING WITH IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES WE ARE PROUD TO
SPONSOR THIS BILL AND URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL PLEASE COME UP AND STATE
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ON THIS BILL.
I CAN SEE CHRISTIAN CENTER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATE PAYMENT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
TAKE A BREAK OR NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORK
CALIFORNIA SHOPPERS DRUG SUPPORT.
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES.
POSTED SO [inaudible]
YEAH.
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
[inaudible]
BILL [inaudible]
OKAY.
SOME WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE RESPECT
LAST FOREVER OKAY GREAT SO WE
HAVE A MOTION -- BY SOME
REMEMBER MY PHONE BY SENDING
[inaudible]
AND SORRY.
AND THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
US SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL -- TITLE HI TITLE III STONE.
STONE I BELL.
JACKSON.
JACKSON I CAN I CAN I WINNER.
THIS WAS.
ABOUT AS FAR AS WE'RE GONNA PUT
THIS PHONE CALL THANK YOU
[inaudible]
OKAY.
SO UP NEXT ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN
OF SOMETHING NUMBER TEN WOULD
YOU -- FEEL FREE TO PRESENT
WHENEVER YOU ARE READY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME NUMBER THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME.
I WATER FATHER THINKING YOU'RE
MAKING TWENTY STAFF FOR ALL THE
HARD WORK ON THE FILM WEEKS OF
MAYBE IN THE NEXT.
THANK YOU AB A SIXTY ARE TRYING
TO COME TO THE ATTENTION OF THE
BAND'S RECORD.
WELL HOME WITH THIS IS NOT A
REASON TO ENTER IN FOSTER CARE
WE KNOW THAT THERE CAN BE YOU
CLICK ON THE STREETS BECAUSE IT
IS SAFER THAN THE HOME THAT THEY
CAME FROM AND FORTUNATELY.
THEY'RE OFTEN LIVING ON THE
STREETS IN THEIR CARS OR
BOUNCING FROM SHELTER TO SHELTER.
WHEN THESE MINERS REPORTS OF
ABUSE OR NEGLECT GO UNDER
INVESTIGATED THE ONLY OTHER
OPTION IS MID AFFIDAVIT? FOR A
JV TO CONFORM TRIGGERING A FINAL
TEMP GETS SOCIAL WORKERS
INVESTIGATE THEIR CLAIM.
WE SHOULD BE DOING WHATEVER IS
NECESSARY RIGHT SAFETY SHELTER
AND A SPEEDY PROCESS FOR THIS
MUCH NEEDED.
USE THIS BILL PRIORITIZES
HOMELESS YOUTH YOU HAVE A
HISTORY OF ABUSE OR NEGLECT WERE
FORMALLY BEEN DEPENDENT OF THE
COURT PRODUCE THE AMOUNT OF
TIMES THAT SOCIAL WORKER HAS TO
FILE.
COMMENCED APPENDICES PROCEEDINGS
OR NOT FROM THREE WEEKS TO TEN
BUSINESS DAYS.
WHICH IS A FOURTEEN CALENDAR
DAYS.
THE CASE OF WHEN THE SOCIAL
WORKER DECIDE TO DO NOTHING
AFTER THESE TEN BUSINESS DAYS
THEN THE MINOR AND THEIR COUNSEL
MAY SUBMIT A PETITION TO THECOURT TO REVIEW THE DECISION.
IF THAT STEP WAS TAKEN THEN THIS
BILL WILL GIVE THE COURT
FOURTEEN DAYS AFTER FORM.
A REVERSE DECISION BY THE SOCIAL
WORKER.
THIS PROCESS IS ONLY USED AS A
LAST RESORT FOR USE WITH CALLS
TO THE HEARTLAND HAD NOT BEEN
ACTED ON THESE ARE KIDS THAT
HAVE CONTINUOUS MAKE CLAIMS OF
ABUSE OR NEGLECT ARE NOW
CONSIDER HOMELESS.
PLEASE HELP ME TODAY TO MAKE
THIS PROCESS FASTER FOR HOMELESS
YOUTH.
HERE WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY
SUPPORTERS BILLS CAN REALLY
LEWIS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YOUTH.
AND PALMER VOCALS FROM BAY AREA
LEGAL AID AND WHO HANDLES MANY
OF THESE.
CASES.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS KHAN REVIEW TIME IS
NOW TURNING AT BAY AREA LEGAL
AID AND I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF A LEGAL IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
EIGHT SIXTY ONE WHICH PROPOSES A
MODERATE REDUCTION IN THE TIME
LINE IN WHICH THE CHILD WELFARE
AGENCY.
MUST INVESTIGATE ALLEGATIONS OF
CHILD ABUSE OR NEGLECT REGARDING
THE SMALL NUMBER OF HOMELESS OR
PREVIOUSLY SYSTEM INVOLVED YOUTH
WHO PETITION FOR AN
INVESTIGATION THROUGH THE FORMAL
PROCESS.
WE HAVE ASSISTED HOMELESS YOUTH
AND SUBMITTING REQUESTS FOR
CHILD WELFARE INVESTIGATIONS
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN AFFECTED BY
THIS BILL.
ALL BASED ON ALLEGATIONS
PREVIOUSLY REPORTED TO THE LOCAL
CHILD WELFARE AGENCIES OR THE
AGENCY EITHER NEVER RESPONDED OR
ELECTED NOT TO INTERVENE.
I PROVIDE THE FOLLOWING TO CASE
EXAMPLES TO ILLUSTRATE THIS
ISSUE AND THE IMPORTANCE OF A
SHORTENED INVESTIGAR
INVESTIGATORY TIMELINE FOR MOST
VULNERABLE YOUTH.
CASE A ALLEGATIONS OF PHYSICAL
ABUSE AND NEGLECT FOR FAILING TO
PROVIDE FOOD AND KICKING THE USE
OUT OF A FAMILY HOME REPORTED TO
THE OCAL CHILD WELFARE AGENCY
AT LEAST TWO TIMES.
THE MINOR SUBMITTED A REQUEST
FOR INVESTIGATION TO THE AGENCY
WOULD RESPOND TO TEN DAYS LATER
THAT THE ALLEGATIONS WERE
UNFOUNDED AND NO PETITION WOULD
BE FILED.
THE MINOR THAN REQUESTED A
HEARING. SIX WEEKS LATER
FOLLOWING TWO DAYS OF TESTIMONY
ON THE SAME ALLEGATIONS.
THE AGENCY AGREED TO FILE A
DEPENDENCY PETITION. THIRTY
THREE DAYS LATER THE MINOR WAS
DECLARED A DEPENDENT.
HE'S TO ALLEGATIONS OF PHYSICAL
ABUSE AND NEGLECT ON THE BASIS
OF FAILURE TO PROVIDE BASIC
SUPPORT WERE REPORTED TO THE
LOCAL CHILD WELFARE AGENCY ON AT
LEAST THREE OCCASIONS OVER TWO
MONTHS.
THE MINOR THEN SUBMITTED AN
INVESTIGATION REQUEST TO THE
AGENCY AND NEVER RECEIVED A
RESPONSE.
AFTER THREE WEEKS MINOR IN
COUNCIL REQUESTED A HEARING AT
WHICH THE AGENCY WAS ORDERED TO
FILE A DEPENDENCY PETITION WHICH
IT DID TWELVE DAYS LATER.
FIFTEEN DAYS AFTER THAT THE
MINOR WAS DECLARED A DEPENDENT.
TO SUMMARIZE THE AGENCY WAS
AWARE OF AUSE AND NEGLECT
ALLEGATIONS FOR TWO MONTHS PRIOR
TO RECEIVING THE JB.
TWO TEN AFTER SUBMISSION OF
WHICH IT TOO TEN WEEKS BEFORE
THE MINOR BECAME INDEPENDENT.
THESE CASES HIGHLIGHT TWO
PROBLEMS.
FIRST IT CAN TAKE UP TO TWENTY
ONE DAYS FOR A YOUNG PERSON TO
BE ABLE TO FILE UNDER WITH THREE
THIRTY ONE EVEN WHERE THERE IS
NO DECISION MADE.
AND NO INVESTIGATION COMPLETED.
SECOND WHERE THE YOUTH MUST
ULTIMATELY CHALLENGE THE
DECISION IN COURT IT CAN TAKE
ADDITIONAL WEEKS OR MONTHS.
AS OF RIGHT NOW YOU CAN ONLY
REMAIN IN SHELTERS FOR TWENTY
ONE DAYS AND THE CURRENT
STRUCTURE DOES NOT PROVIDE
SUFFICIENT TIME TO COMPLETE THE
PROCESS.
EVEN IF EXTENDED WITH THE
CURRENTLY PROPOSED LEGISLATION
INCLUDING A B. TWELVE THIRTY
FIVE WHICH PASSED OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE TWO WEEKS AGO.
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE STILL WORKING
AGAINST THE CLOCK TO COMPLETE
THIS ENTIRE PROCESS.
THE LONGER YOUNG PERSON REMAINS
IN A SHELTER WAITING
INVESTIGATION THE MORE STABLE AS
THEY BECOME DUE TO INCREASING
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
CONCERNS.
TRANSPORTATION LIMITATIONS THAT
INTERFERE WITH SCHOOL ACCESSING
EDUCATIONAL ENGAGEMENT SARAH.
CURRENT LAW AND REGULATION
ALREADY REQUIRED THAT THE IN
PERSON INVESTIGATION TAKE PLACE
WITHIN TEN DAYS.
WHILE SOME MIGHT FIND THE
PROPOSED TIME WHEN BURDENSOME IT
IS A MINIMAL DIFFERENCE GIVEN
THE MOST INTENSIVE PORTION OF
THE INVESTIGATION MUST ALREADY
BE COMPLETE.
SHORTENING AN INVESTIGATION ONLY
INCREASES ACCESS TO A CRITICAL
SAFETY NET FOR HOMELESS YOUTH
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS OR
PRIOR INVOLVEMENT IN THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM.
WE OFFER STRONG SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL AND ARE AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS.
KEEP IT TO THREE MINUTES PLEASE.
ADAMS KILLERS ARE VISITING A
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YEAR
THAN I AM.
SOME OF MY MEMBERS OPERATE
RUNAWAY AND HOMELESS YOUTH
SHELTERS FOR THOSE WHO ARE UNDER
THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN AND THEN
THESE MINERS CASES ARE STAFF
THAT ARE WORKING WITH THEM ARE
MANDATED REPORTERS.
AND OFTENTIMES MAKE MULTIPLE
CALLS THE HOTLINE IN.
AND AT SOME LEVEL WAY AND WE'RE
NOT ABLE TO HAVE AN
INVESTIGATION COME OUT OR
ANYTHING DO WE JUST CONTINUE TO
CALL THE HOTLINE.
AND HAVE NOBODY COME OUT BECAUSE
WE JUST DON'T KNOW THE STATUS OF
THOSE INVESTIGATIONS THIS IS THE
ONLY MECHANISM IN CODE THAT
REALLY HAS A BACKSTOP. TO BE
ABLE TO WIN OUR FOLKS ARE
WORKING DIRECTLY WITH THOSE YOU.
TO BE ABLE TO HELP THEM TO COME
INTO YOU CARE AND SO.
THE STUDY RESPECT APPRECIATED
AND I ABOUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE
SPELL.
I'D DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
COME ON UP -- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
HEAR.
I WAS AT FAULT [inaudible]
YOU HAVE. EIGHT THE SECOND SORRY
IT'LL BE SANCHEZ SEIU CALIFORNIA
WE SUBMITTED UNOPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION TO THIS MEASURE --
IT IS OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN REJECTED SO.
AT THIS POINT WE UNFORTUNATELY
ARE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE WE
DO APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR STAFF
WILLINGNESS TO SPEND A LOT OF
TIME CHATTING WITH US ABOUT IT
BUT I DID JUST WANT TO WALK YOU
THROUGH.
THE REASONING BEHIND OUR
OPPOSITION AND THE REQUEST FOR
AMENDMENTS -- FIRST OF ALL THE
THE TIME LINE THAT EXISTS UNDER
CURRENT LAW OF TWENTY ONE DAYS
FOR A RESPONSE.
IS ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY I'LL
JUST GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY.
WE HAVE ELEVEN THOUSAND CALLS
EVERY SINGLE MONTH TO OUR CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES HOTLINE IT'S
THE LARGEST CHILD WELFARE
SERVICES.
AND CITY IN THE COUNTRY WHEN YOU
IMPOSE A TIMELINE WHERE BY YOUR
PRIORITIZING ONE SMALL
POPULATION AND PLEASE NOTE THAT
EVERY SINGLE KID.
IS THE MOST IMPORTANT CAT.
BUT WHEN YOU'RE PRIORITIZING A
VERY SMALL POPULATION AND IT'S A
POPULATION THE SCOPE OF WHICH WE
DON'T KNOW THE ONLY INFORMATION
WE'VE.
FROM THE SPONSORS OF THIS
MEASURE ARE EXACTLY WHAT YOU
PERCEIVE TODAY TWO ANECDOTES BUT
THIS BILL SEEKS TO CHANGE THE
LAW FOR ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
RIGHT.
SO WHEN YOU RE PRIORITIZE A
TIMELINE.
IN -- CON CONFLICT WITH EVERY
SINGLE OTHER STATUTORY
REGULATORY OBLIGATION THAT A
SOCIAL WORKER HAS THE PROBLEM IS
YOU'RE REPLACING THE JUDGMENT
EDUCATION TRAINING AND
EXPERIENCE OF THE SOCIAL WORKER
WITH THE STATUTORY OBLIGATION
FOR WHICH THERE IS NO FUNDING TO
ACCOMPANY IT.
WE ABSOLUTELY BELIEVE THAT THE
DOWNWARD PRESSURE ON THIS WILL
CREATE A SITUATION WHERE SOCIAL
WORKERS WHO ARE FOR EXAMPLE
GETTING A CALL TO THE HOT LINE
SAYING.
A HEROIN ADDICTED BABY HAS JUST
BEEN BORN AND NEEDS TO BE PICKED
UP IMMEDIATELY BUT YOU HAVE THIS
TIME LINE WHICH IS SUDDENLY TEN
DAYS IN LIEU OF TWENTY ONE DAYS.
HOW ARE SOCIAL WORKERS WITHOUT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES?
ADDITIONAL SOCIAL WORKER STOP
GOING TO BE ABLE TO ACCOMMODATE
THIS THIS NEW OBLIGATION.
SECONDLY THE BILL SEEKS TO
ADDRESS THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
POTENTIALLY ARE GOING TO BE
KICKED OUT OF HOMELESS SHELTERS
BECAUSE OF THE COMING UP AGAINST
THE TWENTY ONE DAY TIMELINE.
WE A COMPLETELY RECOGNIZED
APPRECIATE THAT THERE IS THAT
CONFLICT BETWEEN THE TWO TWENTY
ONE DAYS THAT'S WHY WE OFFER
GOING DOWN TO NINETEEN DAYS BUT
TO SUGGEST.
THAT THE BULK OF THE
INVESTIGATION IS ACCOMPLISHED BY
THE TEN DAY MARKER WHERE IN THAT
INVESTIGATION IS OBLIGATED IS
NOT ONLY FACTUALLY INACCURATE
BUT WRONG IN PRACTICE.
A LOT OF THE INVESTIGATION HAS
TO TAKE PLACE HOST.
VISIT TO THAT FACILITY.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE'VE ASKED
THAT IT BE WHEN LIMITED TO NO
LESS THAN NINETEEN DAYS WERE
WERE ACCEPTING OF THE FACT THAT
MAYBE A TWO DAY WINDOW WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE.
BUT ALSO WE WERE ASKING THAT IT
BE LIMITED.
JUST TO YOUTH LIVING IN HOMELESS
SHELTERS OF THE PROBLEM THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS IS THE
FACT THAT THEY GET KICKED OUT
THE HOMELESS SHELTERS ON TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUT YOU ONLY HAVE
TWENTY ONE DAYS TO INVESTIGATE.
THEN IT SHOULD ALSO BE LIMITED
JUST TO THE YOUTH THAT ARE
LIVING IN THE HOMELESS SHELTERS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR NUMBERS
CAN BE CENTRALLY WHAT THEY CAN
YOU OFFER DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
TO BE CLEAR WE SENT A LETTER OF
CONCERNS A REQUEST FOR
AMENDMENTS -- WE DO NOT HAVE AN
OFFICIAL OPPOSE POSITION ON THE
LEGISLATION -- BUT BECAUSE
BECAUSE THE CONCERNS ARE
CONSISTENT WITH THOSE OF MS
SANCHEZ EXPRESSED ON AS YET HIS
BEHALF WITHOUT WE COME UP AFTER
HER.
AND JUST SAY -- THAT WE THINK IN
OUR DISCUSSIONS WITH THE AUTHOR
AND SPONSORS THIS GROUP IN
PARTICULAR OF THE HOMELESS
SHELTER YOU'VE HAS COME UP AS
THE THE THE SORT OF MOST
IMPORTANT TO TRY TO ADDRESS.
SO ARE A MOMENT IN ADDITION TO
TRYING TO WORK THROUGH THIS
QUESTION OF HOW MANY DAYS DO
ALSO REQUEST THAT IT BE LIMITED
TO THE CHANGE. FOR THOSE
PARTICULAR YOUTH WERE IN THE
SHELTERS WE DO AGREE THAT A B.
TWELVE THIRTY FIVE WOULD HELP
TAKE SOME OF THE PRESSURE OFF.
EVEN AS THE BILLS -- SITS TODAY
IN ADDITION TO THE TO THE TEN
DAYS THAT WOULD BE GIVEN THAT
WE'RE ASKING TO BE A LONGER
AMOUNT OF TIME.
THE JUDGE WOULD THEN HAVE A
COUPLE OF WEEKS TO FIGURE OUT
WHETHER THEY ACT ON SO WE'RE NOT
SURE THE BILL REALLY ADDRESSES
THE ISSUE. FOR THE YOUTH HER IN
A HOMELESS SHELTERS I MEAN I
THINK THE UNDERLYING ISSUE IS
TWENTY ONE DAYS IS TOO FAST FOR
YOUTH TO BE ABLE TO WHO IS THAT
EXPERIENCE ABUSE OR NEGLECT IN
OUR CURRENT HOUSING SITUATION.
GET INTO THAT NEXT SYSTEM WE
WANT TO BE THERE TO HELP THESE
YOUTH WE SUPPORT THE GOALS OF
THE BILL WE JUST NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT WORKS AND FOR THOSE
REASONS WERE SURE.
CAN YOU KNOW CONVERSATIONS WILL
CONTINUE TO THE MOVE FORWARD AND
I'M SURE WE'LL HAVE SOME
CONVERSATIONS ARE ON THE
FINANCIAL ISSUES AND PROP THIRTY
ISSUES -- IN APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
TAKE A BREAK OR THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORK WE
ALSO APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK THE
AUTHOR IS DONE ON THIS SINCERELY
APPRECIATE THE INTENT OF THE
BILL.
BUT WE ALSO -- ARE UNABLE TO
SUPPORT WHERE AND TWEENER ON
THIS RIGHT NOW FOR THOSE REASONS
STATED THANK YOU.
DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER.
WHAT DO WE HAVE ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO DO
THAT ARE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
[inaudible]
OKAY -- A SMALL NUMBER TEN I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU'D LIKE AN UP
ON OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND.
SURE -- I LIKE TO THINK OF THE
GOAL OF THIS BILL IS NOT TO ADD
ADDITIONAL BURDENS THE SOCIAL
WORKERS.
WE HAVE THE UTMOST RESPECT FOR
BUT RATHER TO STREAMLINE THE
PROCESS AND THAT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY ORIGINALLY THIS BILL
WAS TO HAVE FIVE DAYS.
OF A TURNAROUND TIME WE MADE IT
TO TAT -- ADDITIONALLY -- RIGHT
NOW WE'RE LOOKING AT OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES. ONE OF THE MAIN
SPOKES PEOPLE I'VE SPOKEN TO WAS --
ONE AND A HALF THE KIDS AND ONE
OF THE EXPERTS IN LA COUNTY OF
ADDITIONAL FUNDING SOURCES BUT
AS YOU KNOWTHIS IS GOING TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
I WILL HAVE MORE TIME TO DISCUSS
THE FUNDING ISSUE.
AT THAT MOMENT -- BUT I'M
CERTAINLY AN OPEN TO
OPPORTUNITIES OF WHETHER OR NOT.
TEN DAYS IS APPROPRIATE OR
NINETEEN DAYS BUT AS IT STANDS
RIGHT NOW I THINK RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE A DECENT MIDDLE GROUND.
BUT ALSO LIKE TO TURN IT TO Y
COLLEAGUES RECEIVE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS THAT YOU
LIKE TO MAKE A RESPONSE TO THAT.
AM I WOULD JUST SAY FROM SOME OF
THE HOMELESS SHELTERS WERE
HEARING OF MY YOUTH BETTER
SEVENTEEN WHEN THE CALLS ARE
COMING INTO THE HOT LINE THAT
THERE IS NO INVESTIGATION THAT
COMES OUT.
BECAUSE THE PROCESS ITSELF
GETTING THE YOU THROUGH.
DEPENDENCY COURT IS GOING TO
TAKE A LONG TIME IN THE LATE
JOHN TURNED EIGHTEEN BEFORE YOU
FINALIZE THE DEPENDENCY
PROCEEDING SO.
I THINK THAT'S THAT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS ON THEIR SEVENTEEN IT
MAKES A REALLY CHALLENGING
BECAUSE YOU'RE RUNNING UP
AGAINST THE CLOCK AND SO IF
NOBODY'S ACTUALLY COMING OUT IN
INVESTIGATING.
THANK YOU -- DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- CENTER PAN.
THANK YOU -- SO IF YOU QUIT
FIRST OF ALL JUST TO CLARIFY
THAT I THINK WAS A VISITOR
NOTHER BILL WE'RE HEARING TODAY
TO DEAL WITH THE PEOPLE TURNING
FROM. SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN BIG AT
CELL I MEAN THAT THAT SOUNDS
LIKE A PARTICULAR I MEAN
CERTAINLY A VERY IMPORTANT
SITUATION BUT BUT THIS.
YOU KNOW.
I MEAN.
I UNDERSTOOD THE BILLS NOT JUST
ABOUT ANY IT'S IN TERMS OF
SOMEONE RUNNING OUT THE I GUESS
ABOUT TO TURN.
EIGHTEEN RIGHT I MEAN.
YOU BROUGHT THAT UP THAT.
IS AS WELL AS ANOTHER BILL AB
SOME FORTY EIGHT THAT PASS ON
CONSENT.
LOOK AT AGO YES AND THAT'S WHEN
THEY HAVE GOTTEN THROUGH THE
DEPENDENCY AND SO THAT'LL NINE
TO THIS THAT THE CELL AJANI
CLEARED.
THE THAT IS WHAT SHOULD NO
LONGER BE AN ISSUE PRESUMING
THAT THEY'LL GET SIGNED I MEAN
THIS BUILDING.
OKAY AND THEN I GUESS.
I DON'T KNOW CAN MISS CERTAINLY
NO YOU WILLING TO COME BACK UP.
PRODUCTION BEGAN I SHOULD I THE
BOARD OF WHERE WHEREVER YOU LIVE
YOU AS COMFORTABLE.
OKAY WHEN SHE COULD EVER GET SO.
SO I MEAN AT EIGHT THIRTY THE
THE AUTHOR AND SUPPORTER
CERTAINLY YOU KNOW MAKE A ARE
MAKING THE CASE AND I THINK IT'S
THE IMPORTANT ONE THAT OKAY WELL
YOU HAVE SOMEONE WHO'S HOMELESS
RATE YOU HAVE A CHILD WITH.
HOMELESS WHO NEEDS FOSTER CARE.
AND THERE MAY BE AN SHELTERED
THEY MAY BE OUT IN THE FIELD AND
AND AND DAVE PERHAPS SHOULD HAVE
SOME PRIORITY RIGHT THEY MEAN
DURING A VERY.
SICK CAN YOU SPEAK TO FOR
EXAMPLE OKAY SO WE HAVE TWENTY
ONE DAYS.
I'VE MET ON THE FACE OF A
NINETEEN DOESN'T SOUND LIKE
THAT'S LIKE GIVING A WHOLE LOT --
DO YOU MAYBE SPEAK TO THE
PROCESS BY WHICH IN THAT
ANYTHING THE OTHER WE NEED TO
RECOGNIZE ANY ANY CHILD TO YOUR
LOOK CONSIDERING PUTTING INTO
THE FOSTER CARE PROGRAM IS.
IN AND PROBABLY SOMEWHAT
UNSTABLE PRECARIOUS SITUATION --
THAT WHEN SOMEONE CALLS.
CAN YOU MAYBE SPEAK -- TO RIGHT
NOW -- WHAT SOCIAL WORKERS DUE
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO PRIORITIZE
I MEAN DATE YOU KNOW YOU GOT A
HOLD YOU GOT SEVERAL DIFFERENT
BECAUSE HE TALKED ELEVEN
THOUSAND A MONTH IN LA IN HIM TO
EACH COUNTY AND?
SO -- SO YOU NOW YOU HAVE SOME
YOUTH WHO ARE IN SHELTERS NO
LIKE KATE MIGHT CULTURES AND
THEY'VE GOT A CALL ON FRIDAY
THAT WE HEARD THE COMPLAINT THAT
WELL GEE WE CALL NO ONE EVEN
COMES OUT GREAT -- SO -- SO HOW
I GUESS MY QUESTION TO YOU IS IS
TELL ME A LITTLE ABOUT THAT
PROCESS AND HOW YOU CAN GIVE ME
CONFIDENCE THAT THE SOCIAL
WORKER JUDGMENT IS IN TERMS OF
TRYING TO PRIORITIZE A
SUFFICIENT ENOUGH THAT WE SHOULD
STATUTORILY SAY WELL YOU KNOW WE
THINK THESE ARE.
REALLY IMPORTANT KIDS.
AND THEREFORE YOU SHOULD DO THIS
FIRST.
THANK YOU I WILL TRY TO ADDRESS
THOSE QUESTIONS -- KATHY
SINGLING FOR CWD A AGAIN WERE WE
HAVE CONCERNS ON THE BILL WE
DON'T HAVE IT.
IT IS A PROCESS CLARIFY
ABSOLUTELY.
SO -- THE SO THERE'S A COUPLE
THINGS THAT I I I WANT TO SAY IN
RESPONSE TO THAT I THINK -- IF
YOU PROBABLY HAVE A COUPLE
THINGS GOING ON AS MRS SANTOS
NOTED THE EMERGENCY RESPONSE
PROCESS WHEN THE CALLS COME IN.
IS TO TRY TO TALK WITH THE
PERSON AND THAT ASCERTAIN
WHETHER AN IMMEDIATE OR TEN DAY
RESPONSE IS NEEDED OR IF NO
RESPONSE IS NEEDED.
AND SO THERE ARE QUESTIONS AND
THERE'S A DECISION MAKING TOOL
THAT WE UTILIZE IN EACH COUNTY
ALONG WITH THAT THAT PARTICULAR
HOTLINE WORKERS BEST JUDGMENT.
TO TRY TO TRIAGE AND PRIORITIZE
THOSE CASES IT IS A FACT THAT
WERE OPERATING -- IN A SITUATION
WHERE WE THINK AND ARE GOING TO
BE HAVING SOME CONVERSATION
STARTING IN THE FALL WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION.
AND THEN HOPEFULLY BRINGING FROM
CONVERSATIONS HERE TO THE
LEGISLATURE NEXT YEAR ABOUT THAT
EMERGENCY RESPONSE SYSTEM SO I
THINK -- MAKING SURE THAT WE
HAVE THE TOOLS AND THE SOCIAL
WORKERS NECESSARY ON THE GROUND
TO ARM THEM WITH THOSE TOOLS TO
BE ABLE TO MAKE EXCELLENT
DECISIONS AS TIMELY AS POSSIBLE.
IS REALLY CRITICAL AND IT
DOESN'T JUST APPLY TO THE THE
YOUTH OR AT PART OF THIS BILL I
THINK -- IN THE CONVERSATIONS IT
HAS COME UP THAT THE HOMELESS
YOUTH ARE THE ONES THAT APPEAR
TO BE IN THE MOST NEED OF A
QUICKER RESPONSE AND THAT MAKES
SENSE TO US THAT'S WHY WE'RE
SUGGESTING.
LOOK THE GROUP THAT'S IN THE
BILL RIGHT NOW IS PRETTY BROAD
AND SO -- IT'S YOU KNOW ANYONE
WHO'S HAD A PAST EXPERIENCE
ANYONE I THINK THEY'RE SORT OF
THREE GROUPS THAT ARE IN THE
BILL AND SO GIVEN THAT WE KNOW
THAT THERE ARE SOME ISSUES
RELATED TO THE EMERGENCY
RESPONSE PROCESS THAT WE'RE
GONNA BE HAVING GOOD
CONVERSATIONS WITH -- GIVEN THE
INSTITUTION OF VARIOUS TOOLS AND
DECISION MAKING -- THAT IS
SUPPOSED TO FEED INTO OUR
EFFORTS THAT WERE ABLE TO ANSWER
THOSE QUESTIONS TIMELY.
ON THAT THE TEN DAYS DOES SEEM
QUICK TO W. A FULL INVESTIGATION
AND I THINK THE QUESTION IS DO
YOU RUN THE RISK OF THE WORKER.
IN AT SUCH A CIRCUMSTANCE JUST
SAYING UNDER GOING TO SAY NO
BECAUSE I CAN'T GET TO YES
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
BACK THAT UP IF YOU GO TO COURT.
YOU HAVE TO FILE A PETITION AND
YOU HAVE TO HAVE ENOUGH IN THAT
PETITION TO SAY THERE IS
SOMETHING GOING ON HERE AND I
NEED TO BRING THIS YOUTH IN THE
FOSTER CARE.
AND IF THEY CAN'T GET TO THAT
WITHIN TEN OR EVEN TWENTY ONE
DAYS -- I THINK INVESTIGATING A
LITTLE BIT TOGETHER WHAT IS WHAT
HAPPENS AND I THINK THAT MIGHT
BE THE ANSWER TO THE QUESTION IF
THERE'S NOT A RESPONSE AT ALL.
THE LAW IS STRUCTURED TO ME
HONESTLY IN A WAY WHERE.
THE SOCIAL WORKER HAS TO ACT
WITHIN THAT TWENTY ONE DAYS.
BUT THERE'S NO REAL PRESUMPTION
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS IF THEY DON'T
AND SO THE ANECDOTES THAT WE'VE
HEARD AND I THINK THE ANECDOTES
WERE PRESENTED TODAY I DIDN'T.
COMMIT THEM TO MEMORY SEEMED IT
SORT OF HAVE THE SORT OF LIMBO
WHERE YOU'VE MADE THIS REPORT
AND THEN NOTHING HAS HAPPENED
AND THEN THE HANDS ARE TIED TO
DO ANYTHING AND GO ON TO THE
NEXT STEP I MEAN MAYBE THAT'S
SOMETHING TO LOOK AT AND SAY IF
WE'VE.
HAD THAT TWENTY ONE DAYS AND THE
ANSWER IS LOOK I'M STILL WORKING
ON IT I'M TRYING TO GET A FAST
AND THERE'S BEEN AN ENGAGEMENT
THAT'S ONE THING IF THERE HASN'T
BEEN A DECISION MADE.
AND IT'S DIFFICULT TO GET A HOLD
OF THAT PERSON WITH A COPY AT
THAT WERE HAVING A CONVERSATION
SEPARATELY -- MAYBE THERE'S
SOMETHING TO SORT OF PROCEED TO
THE PROCESS WITH THAT THAT.
I DON'T KNOW PUT THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY.
BUT ALSO DOESN'T ELEVATE ALL OF
THOSE PARTICULAR YOUTH IN THAT
GROUP THAT THE BILL CURRENTLY
ELEVATES INTO THAT FASTER OR YOU
KNOW KIND OF NEXT STEP PROCESS I
FEEL LIKE THERE'S SOME WAYS TO
GET OUT THIS.
THAT ARE NOT EXACTLY WHAT THE
BILL DOES BUT THAT MAY TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THE KIND OF THE WORKLOAD
IMPLICATIONS IT WOULD BE HELPFUL
TO HAVE SOME MORE INFORMATION ON
THE NUMBERS WE DON'T I CAN'T GET
OUT THAT I DON'T I DON'T SEE HOW
TO GET THAT IN THE DATA.
I'M SORRY IT'S KIND OF A LONG
WINDED ANSWER BUT LIKE WE'RE
TRYING WE SEE THE NEED FOR THESE
USED TO BE SAFE WE DON'T WANT
THESE USED TO BE IN DANGER.
THAT'S I THINK EVERYONE CAN
STIPULATE TO THAT THE QUESTION
IS WITH IN OUR CURRENT SYSTEM
AND STRUCTURE HOW DO WE MAKE
THAT WORK AND WE JUST DON'T
THINK THIS BOOK LIKE IT THAT IT.
OKAY.
THAT'S VERY HELPFUL I APPRECIATE
THE EXPLANATION BECAUSE I THINK
YOU KNOW -- BRIDGE WHAT THE
AUTHOR IS TRYING TO DO AND
SPONSORS AND WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO.
I THINK THE QUESTION IS IS THAT
THE RIGHT SOLUTION AND THAT'S
READ SOMETIMES LIKE OKAY
QUESTION IS IF WE JUST SHORTEN
THE DEADLINE IS THAT GOING TO
WHAT WHAT WHAT'S GOING.
TO WHAT WILL HAPPEN WHAT A
POTENTIALLY GET ATTEND THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THAT AND THAT'S
WHY I'M TRYING.
TO FIGURE OUT IS SOMEONE WHO
ALSO YOU KNOW IF IT'S ON THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE AND YOU KNOW
WE TALK ABOUT WHAT KIND OF
RESOURCES WERE GETTING THE
COUNTIES AND SO FORTH.
AND MAY WE NEED TO EVISIT SOME
OF THAT I THINK THAT'S THE ISSUE
IF YOU JUST SAY NO NO REALLY DO
IT I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S ENOUGH.
TO FIX THE OVERALL ISSUE OR
UNDERLYING ISSUES.
THANK YOU.
THUNDERSTORMS THANK YOU -- YOU
KNOW FOR WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
KIDS THAT ARE IN CRISIS AND GOTA CAR LOAN ALLOWS THESE RUNAWAYS
AND USED TO STAY IN THESE HOMES
FOR TWENTY ONE CONSECUTIVE DAYS
AND AND I WANT TO PLUG THE
AUTHOR. FOR FOR TRYING TO GET TO
THESE -- THESE THESE KIDS IN
TROUBLE A LOT SOONER AND I SING
IN MY REPORT THAT -- IF A SCIAL
WORKER -- DOES NOT FILE A
JUVENILE COURT PETITION WITHIN
THE TEN DAYS OF THE APPLICATION
THE SOCIAL WORKER MUST JUST
DOCUMENT FOR ANY REASON NOT
FILING.
IN NOTIFYING THE APPLICANT OF
THE DECISION SO IT DOES GIVE YOU
AN OUT IF YOU CAN'T GET TO THE
ACCOMPLISH GOALS WITHIN.
OF THE TWENTY ONE DAYS BUT YOU
KNOW WITH.
WE JUST GOT THROUGH TALKING
ABOUT HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND WE
WE HAVE KIDS THAT ARE -- IT AT
RISK AND WE NEED TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO SHORTEN THE
TIME FRAME MAYBE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE DAYS IS TOO LONG AND MAYBE
TEN DAYS A LITTLE BIT TOO SHORT.
BUT I WANT I'D LIKE TO HEAR MORE
ON THE SIDE OF TEN DAYS AND I
WORK WITH LIKE.
SOCIAL WORKERS IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY THAT JUST DOING YEOMAN'S
JOB AND AND SOMETIMES -- YOU
KNOW ALL DEPARTMENT SOMETIMES
THE A LITTLE INCENTIVE.
AFTER SOME LEGISLATION TO GET
THINGS TO MOVE FASTER THE GEARS
OF GOVERNMENT ON ALWAYS WORK
THAT FAST BUT HERE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT -- CHILDREN'S LIVES AND SO
YOU KNOW -- I'M.
WHEN HEARING THAT MAYBE THE
AUTHORS WILLING TO CONTINUE TO
TO TALK WITH THE OPPOSITION I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT WE
MOVE THE BILL FORD I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT FOR THE?
HEALTH THE SAFETY OF OUR OUR
YOUNGSTERS TO FIND THEMSELVES IN
THIS -- VERY UNFORTUNATE
SITUATION.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS I LIKED
WITH THE BILL.
DO WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I JUST THE I I WOULD.
THE I APPRECIATE THE BILL AND
AND MY BIG FRUSTRATIONS I THINK
WE'RE JUST UNDER.
SERVICING THIS IMPORTANT AREA
UNDER YOU KNOW FUNDING IT UNDER
SOURCING IT -- IT'S HARD TO
CREATE HOW DO YOU PRIORITIZE
THESE KIDS ARE ALL IN NEED AND
THEY'RE ALL ENTITLED TO WHATEVER
WE CAN DO FOR THEM BUT IT IS MY
HOPE THAT AS WE GO FORWARD WE
RECOGNIZE THAT.
AS HUMAN BEINGS ARE ENTITLED TO
THE BEST WE CAN GIVE THEM AND
HOPEFULLY WILL BE PUTTING MORE
INTO THE PROCESS AND NO I THINK
WE NEED MORE SOCIAL WORKERS I
THINK WE'RE WE NEED TO PAY THEM
BETTER.
THAN THAT THEY ARE AN IMPORTANT
ELEMENT IN OUR SOCIETY IN IN THE
FABRIC OF OF YOU KNOW.
TRYING TO TRYING TO HELP THE
NEXT GENERATION BE CONSTRUCTIVE
PARTICIPATING AND THE WELL
ADJUSTED PEOPLE -- IN THE
CHALLENGES ARE IN THESE
INSTANCES CAN BE ENORMOUS SO.
I I APPRECIATE ALL THE COMMENTS
MADE I APOLOGIZE HAVE BEEN IN
AND OUT OF IN THIS BUT I THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THE BILL AND I
THANK YOU FOR THE WORK YOU'RE
DOING AND AND YOU KNOW WE JUST
HAVE TO KEEP BANGING THIS FROM
BECAUSE THESE ARE.
VULNERABLE YOUNG PEOPLE AND THE
THE NOTION THAT WE TRAFFIC THEM --
OR THEY ARE TRAFFICKED AND WE
DON'T WE'RE NOT THERE TO HELP --
THE FACT THAT THEY HAVE THESE
THESE KIND OF OUR NEEDS THAT
ANYONE WOULD HAVE UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THEIR LIVES --
HISTORY -- SO I I JUST THE THANK
YOU AND AND HOPE THAT WE CAN.
WE CAN RECOGNIZE HIM PORTENTS OF
COMMITTING TO THESE KIDS GOING
FORWARD.
I THANK YOU I'M SORRY I I THIS
IS IMPORTANT BILL AND I I
SUPPORT AND THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD -- I I
TOTALLY UNDERSTAND THAT THERE
ARE -- RESOURCE CONCERNS FROM
THE COUNTIES AND OFFER MESSY I
YOU AND I DON'T DOUBT THOSE
RESOURCE.
CONSTRAINTS -- AND BUT SOMETIMES
YOU HAVE TO SET THE POLICY.
AND THEN YOU WORK TO MAKE SURE
THE RESOURCES FOLLOW AND I THINK
A LOT OF YOU KNOW FOR GONNA.
WAIT FOR THE RESOURCES TO ENACT
IN FOREIGN POLICY -- A LOT OF
TIMES ARE IN WAITING A LONG TIME
ONCE WE SET THE POLICY.
THE RESOURCES -- CAN FOLLOW AND
pTHAT HAPPENS BUT I DON'T THINK
IT'S A REASON NOT TO MOVE FOR A
GOOD POLICY TO PROTECT SOME VERY
VERY VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS IN
OUR STATE.
SOME OF THE NUMBER TEN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR TIME AGAIN WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR ALL THE
GREAT WORK THEY'VE DONE.
AGAIN -- I HAVE THE UTMOST
RESPECT FOR SOCIAL WORKERS AND
IS NOT MY INTENT TO ADDITIONAL
BURDENS TO THE SOCIAL WORKERS
AND THE PROCESS WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IS PRIORITIES.
THE CASE WORK IT DOESN'T ADD
ADDITIONAL LOADS TO THAT CASE
WORK AND SPEAKING TO SOME
EXECUTIVES OVER AND DCFS FROM
CHILDREN FAMILY SERVICES OR
FRIEND LA COUNTY.
THEY'VE CAME UP WITH CREATIVE
WAYS IN TERMS OF RESOURCE WISE
TO LOOK AT WHAT THE NEXT STEPS
OF POSSIBILITIES OF ADDING
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES.
AND IN LA COUNTY IN THE VARIOUS
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES WE HAVE
HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OF UNSPENT PROCESS THREE FRONTS
MEDICAL SERVICE I DOLLAR FUNDS.
AND ACCORDING TO THEM THERE IS A
LARGE PORTION OF THOSE USE THOSE
HOME WITH USE WHICH HAVE
CORPORATISM DISORDERS.
BUT THEY HAVE A MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUE IN THE OFFICE.
SUBSTITUTE -- MEDICAID WITH DRUG
AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND THAT IS
A POSSIBILITY FOR THIS RESOURCE
BUT I'M JUMPING AHEAD OF THE GUN.
I THINK IF GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY
PASSES COMMITTED WHEN IT GOES ON
THAT COMMITTEE I ASSURE YOU AND
GIVE YOU MY SOLEMN PROMISE TO
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION.
OF FINDING A TIME BUT THE TEAM
ALSO APPROPRIATE IT IS MY INTENT
THAT WITHIN THIS THREE WEEK TIME
FRAME AS IT STANDS RIGHT NOW.
MANY YOU WITH MANY CHILDREN FALL
THROUGH THE CRACKS IT IS MY
INTENT THAT WE CAN TRY TO STOP
AT THE CURB SOME OF THAT -- FROM
HAPPENING SO THAT IS WHY WHEN
THIS BILL FOR STARTED WAS FIVE
DAYS NOW IT'S AT TEN SO WHAT YOU
HAVE MY SOLEMN PROMISE FROM ME
AND MY STAFF THAT IF GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO WORK CLOSELY
WITH THE OPPOSITION -- ON
FINDING A MEDIUM GROUND.
THANK YOU SO MUCH -- WE DO HAVE
A MOTION BY SENATOR STONE I AND
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO SENATE JUDICIARY.
US SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL A TITLE I TITLE III STONE.
STONE HI BEL.
JACKSON.
JACKSON I PAN.
WINNER.
WINNER I FOUR ZERO SO THE VOTE
IS FOUR ZERO WE WILL I'LL HOLD
IT OPEN IT JUST ALLOW OTHERS THE
YUP TREAT ABOUT THANK YOU.
NEXT WE HAVE AGENDA ITEM. NINE
AB SEVEN ONE EIGHT AND THERE
AFTER WE HAVE [inaudible]
AGENDA ITEM. SEVEN EIGHTY SIX
ONE TWO SORRY NOT THAT ROOM.
NOT.
ITEM NUMBER -- SIXTEEN EIGHTY
NINE FORTY TWO A SOMEONE A BREAK
MY PLEASE FEEL FREE TO START
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
YOU VERY MUCH ENDED AT WHILE I'M
SITTING HERE BUNCHES AUGUST BODY --
AND LISTENING TO LAST A
CONVERSATION I WANT I BET.
YOU WOULD ALL BE SURPRISED TO
KNOW THAT THERE'S NO TITLE
PROTECTION FOR SOCIAL WORKERS.
SO COUNTY'S DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES CPS THEY CAN HIRE
ANYBODY LIKE THAT THEY THINK IS
QUALIFIED EVEN IF THEY DON'T
HAVE AN MSW AND CALL THEMSELVES
A SOCIAL WORKER.
SO THIS IS SOMETHING I HOPE MY
FRIENDS IN THE ROOM -- WHO HAVE
OPPOSED ME EVERY TIME WE TRY TO
DO SOMETHING AROUND TITLE
PROTECTION -- JUST MIGHT THINK
ABOUT LOVE IT MORE WAS IT WAS A
GOOD OPENING I JUST THOUGHT I
WOULD ADDRESS THE ISSUE.
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
PROFESSIONAL SOCIAL WORKERS
GOING OUT AND DOING ASSESSMENTS.
I THINK IT'S A GOOD TO HAVE AN
ACTUAL MSW OR BSW SOMEBODY WHO
HAS BEEN TRAINED -- IN SOCIAL
WORK AND ALL OF THE SYSTEMS THAT
INTERACT WITH THAT.
TALK TO YOU ABOUT THAT COULD
MAYBE NEXT YEAR.
ANYWAY TODAY I'M HERE TO TALK
ABOUT A. B. -- SEVEN EIGHTEEN
AND CURRENTLY AS YOU KNOW STILL --
PEOPLE CAN NOW STAY IN FOSTER
CARE UP TO THE AGE OF TWENTY ONE
SO THEY CAN GET MRE SERVICES OR
WHATEVER THEY MAY NEED -- BUT
TRADITIONALLY THEY DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO ALL OF THEIR LEGAL
DOCUMENTS THEIR DRIVER'S LICENSE
OR SOCIAL SECURITY CARD AND TO
GO INTO COLLEGE -- AND SOME
PEOPLE START AS YOUNG AS SIXTEEN
GETTING EMPLOYMENT GOING TO
COLLEGE SO THIS WAS THIS SAYS
THAT WE REDUCE THE AGE UNDER
SIXTEEN WHEN THEY GO FOR THEIR
REVIEW.
THAT THEY ARE ALLOWED TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THOSE DOCUMENTS -- AND
ALSO HAVE -- SOME EDUCATION
AROUND HOW DO YOU GET A JOB HOW
TO APPLY FOR FINANCIAL AID AND
DO ALL OF THOSE THINGS WE THINK
THIS EMPOWERS THE THE YOUNG
SIXTEEN YEAR OLD -- TO BE ABLE
TO MAKE SOME MORE DECISIONS AT
THE SAME TIME IS PROVIDING THEM
GUIDANCE AS THEY CONTINUE ON IN
THE FOSTER CARE AGENCY AND WITH
ME TODAY I HAVE JULIE MCCORMICK
FROM THE CHILDREN'S LAW CENTER.
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU CHARTER
TADO COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND THANK
YOU A FAMILY MEMBER EGGMAN FOR
AUTHORING THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION.
I'M JULIE MCCORMICK AN ATTORNEY
WITH THE CHILDREN'S LAW CENTER
OF CALIFORNIA SPONSOR OF EIGHTY
SEVEN EIGHTEEN STILL SEATED
CHILDREN'S AUTHOR CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTS APPROXIMATELY THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND CHILDREN UNDER THE
JURISDICTION OF THE DEPENDENCY
COURT.
IN LOS ANGELES SACRAMENTO AND
PLASTER COUNTY -- TO MY CURRENT
ROLE AS A POLICY ASSOCIATE I
SPENT ALMOST A DECADE IN THE
COURT ROOM PROVIDING DIRECT
REPRESENTATION FOR CHILDREN IN
CARE.
AND WE'VE SEEN FIRST HAND THE
NEED FOR THESE YOUTH TO RECEIVE
THEIR CENTRAL DOCUMENTS AS THEY
BEGIN THEIR TRANSITION TO
INDEPENDENCE. EIGHTY SEVEN
EIGHTEEN WILL BETTER ENABLE OUR
TRANSITION AID USED TO PREPARE
FOR ADULTHOOD.
UNDER CURRENT LAW THE COUNTY
WELFARE AGENCIES MUST MAKE
CERTAIN IMPORTANT DOCUMENTS
AVAILABLE TO A NON MINOR.
WHEN THE COURT IS TERMINATING
THEIR CASE SUCH AS A SOCIAL
SECURITY CARD BIRTH CERTIFICATE
HEALTH AND EDUCATION SUMMARY AND
THE DRIVER'S LICENSE?
UNFORTUNATELY THE CURRENT LAWS
NOW AT ODDS WITH AB TWELVE WHICH
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE UNTIL THE
AGE OF TWENTY ONE NOW MANY MANY
YOUTH ARE CHOOSING TO STAY IN
FOSTER CARE.
PAST EIGHTEEN TO RECEIVE
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT BUT THEY ARE
NOT ABLE TO OBTAIN THESE
IMPORTANT DOCUMENTS.
UNTIL THEIR CASE CLOSES OFTEN AT
THE AGE OF TWENTY ONE THIS DELAY
PRESENTS MANY CHALLENGES TO OUR
NON MINOR DEPENDENCE OFTEN TIMES
WHEN THEY APPLY FOR JOBS OR
FINANCIAL AID OR CERTAIN HOUSING
FACILITIES.
THEY NEED TO PROVIDE THESE
DOCUMENTS YET THEY FIND
THEMSELVES HAVING TO COME TO
COURT TO GET ORDERS JUST TO GET
THOSE DOCUMENTS.
THIS DELAY IS BECAUSE MANY OF
OUR CLIENTS TO LOSE JB AND OR
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES. EIGHTY
SEVEN EIGHTEEN WOULD FIX THIS
ISSUE PROVIDING DOCUMENTS TO OUR
CLIENTS WHEN THEY NEED THEM.
IT IS A MORE SENSIBLE APPROACH
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF AB.
TWELVE EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHTEEN
ALSO PROVIDES TRANSITION AND YOU
WITH THE OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE
IN FINANCIAL LITERACY TRAINING
AND THE SKILLS ARE CRITICAL AND
WILL BETTER PREPARE CLIENTS FOR
THEIR TRANSITION.
OUT OF FOSTER CARE.
AND FINALLY MANY OF THESE
DOCUMENTS ARE REQUIRED TO BE
PROVIDED THIS BILL WILL JUST
CHANGE THE TIME FRAME BY WHICH
THESE IMPORTANT DOCUMENTS ARE
DISTRIBUTED.
AND ASKED THAT THE AGENCY
INCLUDED THE REGULARLY SCHEDULED
REVIEW HEARINGS REPORT ON THEIR
DISTRIBUTION.
I THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION CLC IS
PROUD TO SPONSOR THIS BILL
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR EYES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY DO
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL PLEASE COME UP
STATE YOUR NAME.
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION CHECK
A FIGURE WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORK
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
JESSE AGUILAR JOURNEY HOUSE
STRONG SUPPORT.
KRISTIN PARLANCE TONES RIGHT
SUPPORT.
IN YOUR MALL A CALIFORNIA LINES
OF CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES AND
SUPPORT.
I WAS REPRESENTING A SPARE NAT
AND SUPPORT.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL.
BILL WE HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
HERE -- DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS DR SENATOR PAT
A JUST A QUICK QUESTION SO IN
TERMS OF THE DOCUMENTS -- AND
THAT FIRST OF ALL IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THEY GET OLD DOCUMENTS.
WHEN DO THE WHEN DOES A FAST YOU
FINALLY GET THEIR DUCKS I
UNDERSTAND IT SIXTEEN YOU'RE
GONNA WILL ALLOW THEM TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THEIR SOCIAL SECURITY
CARDS I CAN DO WHATEVER THEY
NEED TO DO WITH IT BUT -- I
UNDERSTAND -- SOME CONCERNS THAT
IF SOME DOCUMENTS GET LOST AT
WHAT POINT DO YOU ACTUALLY
TURNED OVER ALL THE DOCUMENTS TO
APPLAUSE.
WELL I GUESS TO FOSTER YOUTH OR
SOMEONE.
THAT EIGHTEEN IS IT TWENTY ONE
WITH THE THE THE SYSTEM I MEAN
WHAT WHEN WHEN DO THEY ACTUALLY.
LIKE YOU THEY ARE.
CURRENTLY YOU WHEN THEY ARE
TURNING JURISDICTION IN THE CASE
SO -- FOR A LOT OF YOUTH IT'S
TWENTY ONE THIS BILL WOULD
CHANGE THAT AND THEY WOULD GET
THEM AT THE REGULAR SCHEDULED
HEARING BEFORE THEY TURNED.
EIGHTEEN HEY AND HAVE IT OKAY
AND THEN DOES IT.
SIXTY CAN ACCESS A SIXTEEN OKAY
NOW SOME DOCUMENTS YOU CAN HAVE
I REALIZE THAT YOU CAN GET SOME
DUPLICATES YET TWO CERTIFICATES
AT COPIES THIS IS IS THERE A
THERE'S ONLY ONE OF THE I HAVE
THE DOCUMENTS THEY NEED. TO BE
ABLE TO YOU KNOW DO WHATEVER
THEY NEED TO DO RIGHT -- IS IS
IS THERE A WAY TO ALSO HAVE A
BACKUP COPY REALIZING THAT THERE
ARE PARENTS TO TURN -- TO TO SO
THAT -- IN CASE THE REGION'S
THEIR COPY GETS LOST THAT IS
THERE'S A DEFEAT ANY THOUGHT
ABOUT THAT.
ANYTHING FOR MOST DOCUMENTS
YOU'RE ABLE TO APPLY IT WENT TO
LOSE AND YOU CAN.
REAPPLY FOR THEM WHICH IS A
SHORTER DOES HELP THE YOUTH WITH
A FAKE DO GET LOST SO MOST OF
THESE DOCUMENTS EVEN THOUGH YOU
HAVE AN ORIGINAL.
IT'S EASY TO BAN ATTAIN
UNORIGINAL OKAY WELL JUST THIS
WAS SOMETHING I WAS THINKING
ABOUT JUST IN TERMS OF HOW THAT
DID YOU HAVE A TEENAGER DON'T
START.
RIGHT EXACTLY YES SO IT'S ANYWAY
AS HE'S VERY STRONGLY SUPPORTED
THE BILL I JUST WANNA THINK I
THINK IT THROUGH A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE YEAH BECAUSE AT THE
EXACT FUSSY DOESN'T HAVE.
SO I CAN GET TO YOUR PARENTS SO
THEY HAVE SOMETHING BACK IN THE
HOUSE OR SOMEWHERE LIKE THAT
THERE BECAUSE THERE ARE CERTAIN
MORE DETACHED HOW TO BE SURE
THAT THEY HAVE SOME ANCHOR PLACE
THAT THEY'RE BACK.
THAT DOCUMENTS CAN BE FOUND IN
CASE SOMETHING HAPPENS YOU KNOW
WHO KNOWS WHAT.
THE HELL YOU'RE OFF TO COLLEGE
LEAVE SOMETHING BEHIND.
YOU ELLIS WHATEVER SO YOU GOT
MOVED TO ONE HOUSE AND OTHER
THINGS GET LOST THE ADDRESS SO
OKAY.
WELL JUST ONE AFTER QUESTION
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
DO WE HAVE A SO WE HAVE A MOTION
BY SENATOR STONE AND THE MOTION
IS TO PASS THE SENATE JUDICIARY.
A SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
RIHANNA I RETIRED A HIGH STONE.
STONE HI BILL JACKSON.
JACKSON HIGH PAN.
PAN I WINNER.
WE ARE HIGH THAT'S FIVE ZERO SO
THE VOTE IS FIVE ZERO WE WILL
PUT THAT ON CALLED A LOT MOTHERS.
THANK YOU.
UP NEXT WE HAVE AGENDA ITEM
SIXTEEN EIGHTY NINE FOUR TWO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER PLEASE
COME ON UP THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE IN WAITING.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO BEGIN WHEN
YOU ARE READY -- MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FIRST OF ALL
FOR HEARING THE BILL I'M HERE TO
PRESENT TO YOU. EIGHTY NINE
FORTY TWO THE ACCESS TO SAFE
FOOD CHOICE AND FOOD SECURITY
ACT -- THERE ARE APPROXIMATELY
FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE FOOD
INSECURE AND IN DANGER OF
EXPERIENCING HUNGER EVERYDAY.
PEOPLE WHO ARE HOMELESS DISABLED
AND ELDERLY HAVE PARTICULAR.
VULNERABILITIES TO HUNGER AND
BECOMING FOOD AND SECURE.
THE CALIFORNIA FIRST RICH
RESTAURANT MEAL PROGRAM THE RMP
WAS DESIGNED TO SERVE THESE
POPULATIONS RECOGNIZING THE
STRUGGLE WITH THE ABILITY TO
COOK.
AND TO REPAIR THEIR OWN MEALS
LACKED THE FACILITIES TO COOK
AND STORE FOODS SAFELY I LIVE IN
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE LIMITED
ACCESS TO GROCERY STORES.
THE THE RESTAURANT MEAL PROGRAM
ALLOWS QUALIFIED PARTICIPANTS TO
USE THEIR FOOD BENEFITS TO
PURCHASE HOT MEALS.
FROM A QUALIFIED PARTICIPATING
RESTAURANT DELI COUNTER OR STORE
IN A PARTICULAR AND AND
PARTICIPATING COUNTIES.
CALIFORNIA INTERESTING ENOUGH
ONLY HAS TEN COUNTIES
ADMINISTERING THE PROGRAM.
AND LAST YEAR OF THE BILL AB
EIGHTEEN NINETY FOUR WAS CHAPTER
TO ALLOW ALL TWENTY THREE C. IS
USED TO PARTICIPATE.
IN THE RESTAURANT MEALS PROGRAM
REGARDLESS OF THE COUNTY'S
PARTICIPATION.
WHILE EXPANSION OF COW FRESH RMP
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS HAS
OFFERED MEANINGFUL ACCESS TO
FOOD OF SAFE FOOD COULD CHOICES
TO ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIANS.
HUGE GAP FOR MAIN ACCESS AND AND
REMAIN.
THE OPT IN MODEL HAS FAILED TO
ADEQUATELY ADDRESS THE REALITIES
AND GROWING NEEDS OF PEOPLE'S
SITUATION IN THE REMAINING FORTY
EIGHT CALIFORNIA COUNTIES.
AB NINE FOUR THREE WOULD EXPAND
THE RESTAURANT MEAL PROGRAM
STATEWIDE IN CONJUNCTION WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES AND STAKEHOLDERS TO
FURTHER INCREASE FOOD ACCESS
FOOD SECURITY FOOD CHOICES FOR
HOMELESSNESS -- DISABLED AND
ELDERLY RECIPIENTS OF CAL.
FOR THIS BILL IS SPONSORED BY
THE WOMEN'S POLICY INSTITUTE THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN.
ALL OF US ARE NONE THE LORD'S
WORK THE FOUNDATION AND THE MOMS
RISING IN ADDITION TO THE
SUPPORTED BY A MULTITUDE OF FOOD
BANKS AND ADVOCACY GROUPS.
WITH ME TO SPEAK TODAY ON BEHALF
OF AB NINE FOUR FOUR TWO IS
ESPERANZA FOR NASCO WHO IS A
CALIFORNIA SENIOR ORGANIZE A
WOOD UNITED FOR RESPECT.
AND ALSO FORMER FORMER HOMELESS
RECIPIENT OF CAL FRESH LIVING IN
A COUNTRY THAT DID NOT OPT IN TO
THE RMP.
AND JESSICA BARTOLO WHO'S THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY.
YES OKAY THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THAT COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS I SPENT ON STUFF ON
THICK I I AM I CALIFORNIA SENIOR
ORGANIZED EVERYTHING I DID FOR
RESPECT.
AND ALSO A FOLLOW WITH THE
WOMEN'S POLICY INSTITUTE
ECONOMIC JUSTICE TEAM.
I'M A LITTLE OVER A YEAR AGO I
WAS EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
AFTER BEING KICKED OUT OF MY
HOME AND LET GO FROM MY JOB DUE
TO MY GENDER TRANSITION.
ADD THIS CAUSED ME TO BE REALLY
FOOD INSECURE AND NOT ONLY NO
NOT ON THE QUESTION WHERE I WAS
GOING TO SLEEP EVERY NIGHT.
BUT ALSO HOW I WAS GOING TO EAT.
WHEN I WENT INTO THE OFFICE TO
GET MY EBT CARD AND I'D BE ABLE
TO ACTUALLY RECEIVE ASSISTANCE
TO EAT?
I THOUGHT THAT MY PROBLEMS WERE
OVER BUT WHAT I LEARNED IS NOT
BECAUSE I WAS HOMELESS IN ONE OF
pINTO THE RESTAURANT MEALS
PROGRAM.
I COULD NOT USE MY PUBLIC
BENEFITS CARD TO PURCHASE ANY
FOOD THAT WAS HOT ARE PREPARED.
MANY FOLKS THINK THAT THIS IS
JUST ABOUT BEING ABLE TO
PURCHASE FOOD IN A RESTAURANT
BUT IT'S NOT IT'S THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN BEING ABLE TO BUY
SOMETHING THAT I COULD EAT FROM
A GROCERY STORE ARE BEING FORCED
TO LOOK AT FOOD OPTIONS.
I HAD TO PREPARE WHEN I WAS
LEAVING AND MY BOYFRIEND'S CAR
AND HAD NO WAY TO STOREMY FOOD
AND NOWHERE TO KICK IT.
WHAT I LEARNED THROUGHOUT
TALKING TO OTHER PEOPLE WHO ARE
ALSO IN THE SAME SITUATION AS ME
IS THAT THIS PROBLEM IS MASSIVE
ACROSS OUR STATE AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN EASILY FIX
WITH THIS LEGISLATION?
AMANAT FLY WE URGE YOU TO PLEASE
HER EYE ON THIS ASSET THAT WE
CAN TAKE A AN OPT IN MODEL THAT
GOES COUNTY BY COUNTY.
AND MAKE IT A STATE WIDE PROGRAM
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE TO ASK ABOUT THE
WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON MOM
POVERTY.
ONLY JUST TO ADD THAT -- FIFTEEN
YEARS AGO WHEN I WAS A LOCAL.
ORGANIZER -- TO END HUNGER IN MY
COMMUNITY I ORGANIZED TO TRY TO
GET THIS PROGRAM AFTER HAVING
MET SENIORS WHO -- TOLD ME THAT
THEY WHEN THEY GOT THEIR
BENEFITS ON THEIR SNAP CARD THEY
HAD TO CHOOSE.
WHETHER OR NOT TO SELL THE
BENEFITS SO THAT THEY CAN BUY
FOOD.
BECAUSE THEY LIVED ON THE
STREETS IN A COMMUNITY THAT
DIDN'T HAVE A GROCERY STORE --
OR GO HUNGRY AND THAT AND THAT
THE SENIORS TOLD ME THEY'D
RATHER GO HUNGRY -- THIS IS
HORRIFYING TO ME THAT WE HAD
BENEFITS FOR PEOPLE TO USE AND
THEY COULDN'T USE THEM -- AND SO
I ORGANIZE LOCALLY THEY SHOULD
BE EASY TO FIX. TEN YEARS LATER.
THEY SEE MY OWN COMMUNITY WHERE
I WAS ORGANIZING STILL DIDN'T
HAVE.
THE THE THE BENEFIT AND THIS IS
THE BENEFITS ARE THERE IS JUST
HOW DO YOU USE THEM -- AND AND
SO THIS REALLY IS CALLING OUT
FOR A STATEWIDESOLUTION -- THIS
CAN'T HAPPEN IT DOES HAPPEN IN
TEN COUNTIES -- AND WE NEED A
LITTLE HELP FROM THE STATE TO
MAKE SURE THAT GO STATEWIDE SO
WE'RE REALLY GRATEFUL FOR THE
INTRODUCTION OF THIS BILL.
I NEVER THOUGHT -- I'D SEE
SOMETHING LIKE THIS BEEN OR DO
SO THANK YOU AND I OR DRIVE A
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES.
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
PLEASE COME ON UP STAGE NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION.
HI MY NAME IS CHANTE PRASAD WITH
ALAMEDA COUNTY COMMUNITY FOOD
BANK AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU -- CARES WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
CHECK OF RECORD NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORK
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
DOES THE GET A FELLOW WITH THE
WOMEN'S FOUNDATION OF CALIFORNIA
WOMEN'S POLICY INSTITUTE SPONSOR
AND INSTRUCTS SUPPORT.
DONNA CALLING ON BEHALF OF MOMS
RAISING CO SPONSOR AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
PHYSICALLY CASTRUM HAVE WITH THE
LOTUS WAIT THE FOUNDATION A CO
SPONSOR AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU YOUR SON OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
I LET HIM RATHER THAN
REPRESENTING NEXT GEN CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT.
A BIT OFF BOSS ADVOCATE.
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT.
AT THE CENTER OF THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT.
MICRO THE WESTERN SEVERAL MOM
POVERTY THE PROUD MENTOR OF THIS
W. CANTEEN ABOUT THIS BILL.
MILLION BUCKS FOR THE FOOD BANK
OF CONTRA COSTIN SALADO IN
SUPPORT.
THE VEHICLE CITY FELLOW WITH THE
WPI AND ALSO REPRESENTING STABLE
STRONG AND SECURE AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
JESSE AGUILAR WITH JOURNEY HOUSE
IS STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY --
WITNESSES AND OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION ALL RIGHT PUSH
TO HAVE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS US
SENATOR -- CHECK OBVIOUSLY THIS
IS SOME KIND OF POLICY THAT I
CAN'T FOR THE LIFE OF ME FIGURE
OUT.
WHY YOU CAN'T BUY I MEAN YOU'RE
HOMELESS? TO HAVE A WARM MEAL.
IT COULD YOU EXPLAIN WHAT THE I
MEAN WAS THERE ANY THINK I'M
ASSUMING EVEN IF IT WAS FAULTY
THINKING THERE MUST BEEN SOME.
SOME EXPLANATION FOR WHY THEY
LIMITED TRUE TO WHAT KIND OF
FOOD YOU COULD BUT WHAT IS WHO
CARES I MEAN WHY IS THAT WHY WAS
IT AN ISSUE COULD YOU EXPLAIN TO
ME.
WHAT I'M THINKING MAY HAVE BEEN
YEAH I MEAN I THINK JUST BRIEFLY
AT THE PROGRAM ITSELF WAS?
MADE DURING A TIME WHEN PEOPLE
REALLY ONLY BOUGHT FOOD STORES
IT'S AN OLD PROGRAM THE PROGRAM
JUST CELEBRATED FIFTY YEARS.
OF ENDING HUNGER -- REDUCING
HUNGER IN AMERICA -- SO I THINK
THAT -- HOMELESSNESS REMEMBER I
I TRY TO TELL YOUNG PEOPLE WE
DIDN'T USED TO HAVE HOMELESSNESS
LIKE WE HAVE NOW.
THIS IS THAT WE'RE NOT JUST IN A
HOMELESS CRISIS BUT REMEMBER
WHEN WHEN THERE WASN'T PEOPLE
SLEEPING ON THE STREETS ALL THE
TIME WE ACTUALLY USED TO HAVE
THAT IN AMERICA AND WE DON'T
HAVE IT ANYMORE AND AND THE
PROGRAM RULES FEDERALLY.
THIS OPTION HAS ALWAYS BEEN
AVAILABLE BUT BUT PEOPLE REALLY
HAVEN'T HAD TO USE IT -- SO I
THINK THAT THAT'S PART OF IT AND
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF A COUNTY
I UNDERSTAND WHY COUNTY MIGHT.
NOT CHOOSE TO YOU KNOW COUNTY
COW FRESH OFFICE MIGHT NOT
CHOOSE TO ADMINISTER IT IT IS.
IT MEANS THAT THEY HAVE TO KIND
OF CREATE ANIMAL YOU WITH A
RESTAURANT AND THAT'S NOT REALLY
SOMETHING THAT A COW FRESH
OFFICE USUALLY DOES.
AND SO -- YOU KNOW -- WHEN THEY
HAVE SOME SO MUCH WORK TO DO
JUST TO HELP PEOPLE COMING IN
THE DOORS?
I I RESPECT THE REASON WHY THEY
MIGHT CHOOSE NOT TO BUT IT IT IT
MAKES A LOT OF SENSE TO IT TO
CREATE A SYSTEM AT THE STATEWIDE
LEVEL. FOR THEM TO ACCOMMODATE
THAT WORK RIGHT YOU EITHER TO
STREAMLINE THAT PROCESS SO THAT
NOT EACH COUNTY HAS TO HAVE A
POINT PERSON FOR THE RESTAURANTS
THAT WANT TO PARTICIPATE.
YES SENATOR I AM.
I ALWAYS SAY THERE'S A REASON
WHY THE WORD NONSENSE EXIST.
HI THAT WAS THE WORD THAT CAME
INTO MY HEAD THAT I TRY NOT TO
USE IT TO BE NOT ONLY IN
DELICATE IF IDEA IF YOU BEGIN TO
UNDERSTAND IT AND SO THAT COULD
BE WRONG WITH YOU.
OKAY.
WELL IF YOU REALLY UNDERSTAND
pTO UNDERSTAND BECAUSE WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE RATIONALE OF WHAT
THE PROGRAM IS SUPPOSED TO DO.
ALL OF OUR FOOD PROGRAMS TO
PROVIDE PEOPLE WITH FOOD.
AND AND YET WE HAVE SO MANY
OBSTACLES THAT PREVENT US FROM
DOING IT.
AND I HAD NO IDEA THIS ONE NIGHT
WHEN I RAN FOR A FIRST RAN FOR
OFFICE.
I HAD A STUDENT WHO WAS JUST A
STUDENT MIGHT WHO WORKED IN MY
OWN MY CAMPAIGN.
AND SHE STARTED TELLING ME ABOUT
THE CHALLENGES OF USING HER FOOD
STORE HER CAL FOR S. AND SHE HAD
TO LEAVE CAMPUS TO GO GET.
SOMETHING ELSE BECAUSE THE
CAMPUSES DIDN'T WANT TO DEAL
WITH CAL FRESH AN EBT CARDS.
AND SO SHE LOSER PARKING IN THIS
IS SO THERE WOULD BE SO SHE
COULDN'T BUY THE CERTAIN THINGS
ON CAMPUS AND SHE COULDN'T.
AND YOU HAVE TO LEAVE CAMPUS TO
COME BACK AND SOLD SO WE BEGAN
TO SAY WELL LET'S PUT EBT CARDS
ON CAMPUS WELL OF COURSE
UNIVERSITY TOLD US IT WOULD COST
US.
WHAT ABOUT A QUARTER OF A
MILLION DOLLARS PER CAMPUS TO
BUY LITTLE MACHINE?
AND WE ALL BOUGHT INTO IT FOR
ABOUT A YEAR UNTIL A ONE OF THE
CAMPUS CAME AND SAID WE DID THAT.
AND IF SO HOW MUCH IT COSTS IS
ALL ABOUT. TO A FIFTY DOLLARS I
MEAN.
IT.
AND THEREFORE WE GOT EBT CARDS
ON EVERY CAMPUS BECAUSE OUR OUR
ANIMALS TOLLS WAS A HALF A
MILLION DOLLARS A QUARTER
MILLION DOLLARS AND THEY TOLD US
IT WAS TWO HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS.
AND SO WE WHEN EVERYBODY
REALIZED HOW SIMPLE IT WAS WE
JUST DID IT I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEY WERE ADDING WHETHER ADDING
ADDITIONAL STAFF FOR PEOPLE WHO
CARE THE LITTLE MACHINE IN AND
OUT.
I HAVE NO IDEA.
BUT BUT THAT HAS BEEN WE HAVE
BEGUN AS WE PROCESS OF WORKING
WITH WITH THE THE GROUPS HERE.
TO REALLY DISCOVER ALL THE SMALL
THINGS THAT REALLY PREVENT US
FROM THE PROVIDING SOMETHING AS
FUNDAMENTAL AS FOOD TO PEOPLE
AND THAT WE PARTICIPATE IN A
FEDERAL PROGRAM.
THAT IS SO IT DOESN'T COST US TO
DO THIS PROGRAM.
AND YET WE DON'T DO IT IN AND
OUT OF FIFTY SOME ACCOUNTS WE
HAVE.
TEN AND AND WE AND WE HAD
CAMPUSES THAT DID MORE IN
COUNTIES THAT DIDN'T HAVE IT SO
WE THAT'S WHAT WE HAD TO MAKE IT
HAVE AGREEMENT WITH A C. ISSUES
THAT THEY WOULD USE IT ON THEIR
CAMPUSES.
AND SO IT IS IT'S IT IS
SOMETHING THAT YOU LOOK AT AND
THINK.
WHAT IT IS REALLY SIMPLE YOU
KNOW AND YET ONLY TEN COUNTIES
ARE PARTICIPATING -- SO YOU KNOW
WE JUST TRY TO PUSH THIS I THANK
YOU.
BECAUSE I COULDN'T FIGURE THIS
ONE OUT I CAN IMAGINE THE
RATIONALE I'M HAPPY TO MOVE THE
BILL.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR HELP
DO WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OKAY WELL UP.
FROM EVERYONE LASTLY I WON'T.
OKAY SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR JACKSON AND THE MOTION
IS.
THE MOTION IS GOING TO PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS A
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
RICARDO I TITLE II STONE.
STONE HI BEL.
BELL I JACKSON JACKSON I CAN I
CAN I WINNER.
WINNER HI. SIX THANK YOU.
SIX ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT THANK
YOU [inaudible]
OKAY.
SO I'VE NOW WE ARE.
GOING TO TAKE UP ITEMS --
SEVENTEEN TWENTY ONE AT TWENTY
TWO BUT VERY QUICKLY BEFORE WE
DO WITH THAT -- WE ARE GOING TO
TAKE UP FOLKS ONLY ON ITEM
NUMBER.
ONE AND THAT'S AB.
SEVEN TO EIGHT SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
MADONNA I FOR TITLE I DON'T
[inaudible]
I DON'T.
VETTEL BELL I'D JACKSON.
JACKSON I CAN.
I CAN I WINNER.
WINNER ON IT.
IN THE MOTION IS D. PASSED TO
JUDICIARY -- WITH YOUR I VOTED I
THOUGH ARE THE AUTHOR.
TALK TO ME ABOUT DOING -- SO THE
CONGREGATION SENECA COUNTY BUT
IT'LL BE IN THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
SO I DO A BUNCH.
VOTE I BASED ON OKAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR IT IF I
MADE IT I AM AWARE OF THIS AND
WE WILL HAVE FURTHER DISCUSSIONS
ON THE ISSUE [inaudible]
UN -- THE FOR ITEM NUMBER.
ONE WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND DO
THE VOTE AGAIN -- DO WE HAVE A
MOTION. FOR ITEM NUMBER.
ONE SO MOVED AND THAT MOTION IS
TO PASS THE SENATE JUDICIARY.
HELLO HI -- ICE DOWN.
STONE IDEL BELT I JACKSON
JACKSON I PAN HI AND I WINNER
[inaudible] SIXTY THANK YOU.
OKAY ASSEMBLY -- NUMBER WORKS
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PRESENT ITEM
AGENDA ITEM NUMBER.
SEVENTEEN AND THAT'S A BIG. TEN
TWENTY TWO GREAT THANK YOU IF
YOU LIKE HELL FRESH I GOT THREE
BILLS FOR YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS THANK YOU FOR HAVING US
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR THEIR WORK AND WE WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TODAY.
CAL FOR US IS THE STATE'S MOST
EFFECTIVE ANTI HUNGER PROGRAM
CURRENTLY FOUR MILLIN
CALIFORNIANS RECEIVE CAL FIRST
BENEFITS.
FEDERAL WELFARE REFORM
IMPLEMENTED STRICT TIME LIMITS
TO ABLE BODIED ADULTS WITHOUT
DEPENDENCE OR IS WHAT'S REFERRED
TO AS A BODS RECEIVING SAT
BENEFITS UNLESS AN INDIVIDUAL
LIVES IN A STATE OR COUNTY WITH
A WAIVER.
WORKS AN AVERAGE OF TWENTY HOURS
OR IS GRANTED AN INDIVIDUAL
EXEMPTION.
THE CURRENT FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION HAS PROPOSED
RULES TO ELIMINATE THESE WAIVERS
FOR THE A. BY TIME LIMITS WHICH
WILL DRASTICALLY RESTRICT THE
STATES FLEXIBILITY TO PROTECT
THESE HIGHLY VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS.
THE USDA REPORTS THAT THE
INDIVIDUAL IS LIKELY TO BE CUT
OFF BY THE TIME LIMIT HAVE AN
AVERAGE MONTHLY INCOME OF
APPROXIMATELY 70% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL.
AND QUALIFY FOR NO OTHER INCOME.
THIS POPULATION
DISPROPORTIONATELY INCLUDES
PEOPLE OF COLOR FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES AND FAMILY
CAREGIVERS.
MAYBE TEN TWENTY TWO PROVIDES
BENEFITS TO PREVENT HUNGER AND
ACCESS TO CAL FRESH EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING PROGRAMS TO INDIVIDUALS
WHO LOSE ELIGIBILITY. FOR
FEDERALLY FUNDED CAL FOR US DUE
TO THE STRICT TIME LIMITS.
BASICALLY THIS BILL IS IS SET
HERE BECAUSE IT'S OUR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DEBATES THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF SOCIAL SAFETY
NETS I THINK IT'S INCUMBENT UPON
THE STATE OF CALFORNIA AND THIS
BODY. TO INSURE THAT WE HAVE THE
SOCIAL SAFETY NET FOR THE FOLKS
WHO NEED IT MOST -- THAT'S WHY
I'M HERE AND WHY I THINK MANY OF
US ARE HERE TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE THAT STRONG SOCIAL SAFETY
NET -- THIS BILL HAS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN THE ASSEMBLY AND I
WANT TO THANK OUR SPONSORS THE
WESTERN CENTER.
ON LAW AND POVERTY CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS FOOD
BANK OF KOSTER CONTRA COSTA AND
SOLANO.
ALAMEDA COUNTY CAN BE COMMUNITY
FOOD BANK THE PUBLIC INTEREST
LAW PROJECT AND MANY OTHERS WHO
ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THIS.
I WOULD PLAY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE
AND I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE MY
WITNESSES HERE SELF IDENTIFIED.
YOU DON'T MIND THAT I UP YOU
HAVE A COUPLE NUMBERS I WILL
NEED TO LEAVE -- SHORTLY SO --
YOU KNOW I'M JUST ASKING IF YOU
WERE A WHAT HE'S ACTUALLY TODAY
BRIEF YES KEEP IT PRETTY YES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO THINK ABOUT THE WAY
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND WE'RE HERE TO JUST --
THANK YOU THERE ARE WITNESSES
HAVE COME FORWARD TO SHARE THEIR
PERSONAL STORIES AND WE
APPRECIATE THEM IT'S NOT EASY
AND THEY COME ALL THE WAY TO
SACRAMENTO TO DO THAT AND TO
WORK WITH US TO PUSH BACK
AGAINST THESE FEDERAL PROPOSALS.
THANK YOU.
HELLO THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
TODAY MY NAME IS BUT THREE
SEVERAL MID AUGUST FEVERS NIGHT
LIVE VALLEJO CALIFORNIA.
AND JUST A LITTLE BIT STORY
ABOUT MYSELF -- I WORKED YEARS
IN CORPORATE AMERICA -- WITH --
GETTING MY DOWNSIZING PAPER WORK
AND LOST MY JOB AFTER TWENTY
NINE AND A HALF YEARS.
I WENT THROUGH MY UNEMPLOYMENT
MY SEVERANCE PAY I WENT THROUGH
MY UNEMPLOYMENT AND ENDED UP
EXHAUSTING MY ENTIRE FOUR OH ONE
K..
CELL I RESULTED IN HAVING TO GO
AND GET ON PUBLIC ASSISTANCE.
ARE TRYING TO FIND A JOB AND NOT
BEING ABLE TO FIND A JOB DURING
THAT TIME FRAME I CAN TOTALLY
UNDERSTAND WHERE PEOPLE ARE
LOOKING FOR JOBS CANNOT FIND A
JOB.
AND THEY GET PUT ON ON THAT
PUNISHED ACTUALLY IN MY EYES
WHERE THEY GET TAKEN AWAY THEIR
PUBLIC ASSISTANCE IS TAKEN AWAY
FROM THEM.
AND CAN'T AND CAN'T EVEN EAT SO
AT THIS POINT WITH THOSE.
YOU KNOW PEOPLE GETTING.
THESE TIME LIMITS LIMITS THAT
ARE PUT ON THEM AND THEY GET.
THEY LOSE THEIR ASSISTANCE AND
CAN'T GET BACK ON TO ANY KIND OF
PUBLIC ASSISTANCE WITHIN A
THIRTY SIX MONTH.
OF TIME FRAME IS JUST LUDICROUS
IN MY EYES SO I WITH THAT BEING
SAID I DO ASK FOR YOUR EYES.
ON A. B. TEN TWENTY TWO THANK
YOU.
HI AM THEY ARE RIGHT AND I'M ON
THE VICTIM OF THE SITUATION
THAT'S GOING ON THE FOOD STAMP
PROGRAM I WAS.
DISCONTINUED BECAUSE I WAS TWO
DAYS LATE. FOR THEM OUT SOME
PAPERWORK AND I DID PAPERWORK
THEY MADE ME WAIT TWO MONTHS
[inaudible]
CELL.
I HAD -- YOU SOMETHING THEN ONLY
PROBABLY WOULDN'T DO.
SAD TO SAY BUT I'M ONLY I'M NOT
GONNA BE ONLY BECAUSE YOU HUNGRY.
IF THIS MAKE ANY SENSE TO YOU SO
I WON'T TAKE THAT PIECE OF RAVE
RIGHT THEY'RE NOT GONNA BE
HUNGRY.
AND IF THEY DON'T DO ANYTHING
ABOUT THE SITUATION FOR US CAN
PEOPLE ALL.
FOR THEM THIRTY SIX MONTHS THAT
FOR THREE MONTH PERIOD AS AS AS
LUDICROUS BECAUSE I MEAN.
A LOT OF CRIME GOING ON AROUND
THIS WORLD IS THAT GOING TO BE
THAT IS FINE NICE RELIABILITY
CRIME.
INSTEAD THEY SAY BUT THAT'S WHAT
IS GOING TO BE.
SEAN HOW GOD WHAT AN ISLAND IS.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I APPRECIATE YOUR
HEARING THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS VERY BAD OFF I'M A
THIRTY NINE YEAR OLD HE WOULD
RESIDENT ORIGINALLY FROM SANTA
ROSA I HAVE HEALTH ISSUES THAT
PREVENT ME FROM BEING ABLE TO
WORK I HAVE POST TRAUMATIC
STRESS DISORDER FROM EXPERIENCE
TRAUMA IN MY CHILDHOOD.
I GOT MY GED AT AGE TWENTY ONE
BECAUSE IT WAS IMPORTANT TO ME.
NOT TO MENTION I ALSO GOT A
COLLEGE -- HIGHER EDUCATION OF
THE COMPUTER SCIENCE AND
PSYCHOLOGY ASSOCIATES.
SO IT'S NOT LIKE I'M NOT
EDUCATED ENOUGH I SHOULD BE ABLE
TO STEP UP AND GET ONE OF THE I.
JOB HERE.
IT'S NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE.
I'LL GET BACK TO MY RUDE
AWAKENING HERE I OPPOSED MAX
STRANDS VARIANCE AND FROM MY
CHILDHOOD WE ALREADY WENT OVER
THAT.
I GOT MY GED AGE TWENTY ONE
BECAUSE IT WAS IMPORTANT ME BUT
I BECAME ADDICTED TO HEROIN AT
AGE.
TWENTY THREE I GOT A LARGE AT
SYSTEM MY HIP IN MY EARLY
TWENTIES WHICH LEFT ME WITH
SCIATIC I AM IN LARGE INTENDED
SCARRED AND ABLE TO SIT OR STAND
FOR LONG PERIODS OF TIME.
I AM CURRENTLY TRYING TO GET SSI
GET A HUNDRED NINETY TWO DOLLARS
A MONTH IN CAL FOR ASH.
I PRETTY MUCH ALWAYS BEEN HOME
WITH HER COUCH SURFING AND
SURVIVED BY GETTING CAL FRESH.
I'M ALMOST FORTY YEARS OLD THIS
IS GONE ON SINCE I WAS ABOUT AGE.
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR I KNOW
THIS IS [inaudible] TOO MUCH.
I PRETTY MUCH ALWAYS BEEN
HOMELESS OR COUCH SURFING AND
SURVIVED BY GETTING CAL FRESH IF
I LOST MY CAL FRESH MY ABILITY
TO EAT WOULD BE EVEN MORE
CURTAILED THAN EVER PLEASE --
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY AND AT THIS
MOMENT WILL TAKE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
AT THE CENTER WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT.
IN LOS REPRESENTING THE JEWISH
VOCATIONAL SERVICES OF SAN
FRANCISCO AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU YOUR SON FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS AND STRONG SUPPORT.
HI SHANTI PER SIDE WITH ALAMEDA
COUNTY COMMUNITY FOOD BANK IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND IF I HAVE A
COUPLE OF MINUTES I'D LIKE TO
READ SOME TESTIMONY FROM SOMEONE
WHO COULDN'T BE HERE.
NOW YES [inaudible]
OKAY THANKS.
HI CASSIDY CARMEN BEATS FOOD
BANK OF COUNTRY COSTUME FOR LANA
AND STRONG SUPPORT.
MARIANNE BUGS IN THE FOOD BANK
OF CONTRA COSTA SLOT ON STRONG
SUPPORT.
KEVIN ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT.
ALICIA SIMPLER RUBICON PROGRAMS
AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY A
WITNESS AS OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
AND CRITICALLY.
OF QUESTION THE COMPANIES ARE
VERY CENTER JACKSON -- SOUNDS
LIKE SCHOENFELD SHOWN BACK IN
THE U. R. AWFUL TERROR LEARN
THIS ROB UP -- AMAZING THAT WE
STILL HAVE TO AND I APPRECIATE
YOU KNOW YOU CAN EAT.
OR THE OTHER YOU'RE GONNA GET
SOME FOOD IN YOU NEED TO EAT --
IN HERE WE HAVE BILLIONAIRES WHO --
ORIN WILLING TO TO HELP THOSE
WHO NEED.
A AT ANY RATE MY QUESTION IS.
BASED UPON THE FACT THAT MOST OF
THE SPORTS SEEMS TO BE FROM THE
FROM NORTHERN CALIFORNIA BUT MY
UNDERSTAND THIS IS A STATE WIDE
PROGRAM.
AND COULD YOU THE KIND OF
ELABORATE WHY PERHAPS SOME OF
THE FOLKS FROM OTHER PARTS
CALIFORNIA.
HAVEN'T.
KINDA WEIGHED IN ON THIS -- THAT
YOUR QUESTIONS ARE REALLY GOOD
ONE SO -- WITH REGARDS TO THE
SUPPORT LIST ON THE ON THE BILL --
SO THE THE BILL'S SPONSORS ARE
COMING FROM NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND THE REASON FOR THAT IS
BECAUSE THE TYPES OF WAIVERS
THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
AT THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS
PROPOSING TO LEMONADE OR CALLED
AREA WAIVERS -- AND THERE'S A
GROUP OF COUNTIES THAT THIS YEAR
ALAMEDA COUNTY CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY AND MARIN COUNTY HAVE
BENEFITED FROM THESE.
LOCAL WAIVERS.
ON AND AND SO IT'S THERE THAT
THE ORGANIZING STARTED FIRST.
AM WE'VE BEEN MEETING FOR ABOUT
TWO YEARS -- WITH LOCAL
ADVOCATES AND BRINGING IN PEOPLE
WHO ARE IMPACTED -- IN ORDER TO
PREPARE FOR NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
RESPONSE AS TO THE PROPOSAL BUT
IF IF THE TRUMP RULE BECOMES
FINAL -- IT WILL IMPACT EVERY
SINGLE COUNTY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA EXCEPT FOR IMPERIAL
COUNTY ONLY IMPERIAL COUNTY WILL
HAVE UNEMPLOYMENT HIGH ENOUGH TO
BE DEEMED ELIGIBLE FOR A COUNTY
WAIVER -- WHICH MEANS THERE'S
ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS WHO WILL -- VERY
QUICKLY -- BE ELIGIBLE ONLY FOR
THREE MONTHS WORTH OF COVERAGE
BENEFITS AS YOU HEARD FROM BARRY --
THE BENEFIT IS A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY A HUNDRED NINETY TWO
DOLLARS A MONTH.
THAT'S LESS THAN TWO DOLLARS
ABOUT IT A DOLLAR FORTY TWO PER
MEAL -- THIS IS NOT A LOT OF
MONEY AND IT'S WHEN IT'S ALL YOU
HAVE ON IT IT'S EVERYTHING YOU
HAVE.
WAS TALKING ABOUT.
YOU'RE NOT GETTING ANYTHING
WARRANTY YOU'RE LUCKY TO GET A
QUOTE TRANSACTION FEES.
CAN YOU CAN ORDER.
SO WE HAVE [inaudible]
A BUT JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE THINKS.
WE HAVE A MOTION -- BY SENATOR
BELL AT THE MOTIONS TO DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
RICARDO I RETIRED -- I ASKED HIM.
BELL.
BELL I JACKSON.
JACKSON I CAN I CAN I WINNER.
WINNER HI.
SO THE BOAT IS FIVE ZERO AND
THAT BILL IS OUT.
THANK YOU YEAH.
THANK YOU.
AND WE ARE GOING
TO CLUB BRIEFLY OPEN UP THE ROLL
CALL FOR ON CALL ITEMS BEFORE WE
MOVE ON TO I ITEM TWENTY ONE AN
ITEM.
TWENTY TWO SO OUR SECRETARY IF
YOU CAN PLEASE OPEN UP THE ROLL
CALL FOR ON CALL ITEM. EIGHTY
ONE SEVENTY FIVE GIBSON -- THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE CHAIR VOTE
SIGH BELL.
BELL I JACKSON.
JACKSON HIGH.
SIX ZERO ARE EXTREME TV FIVE I'M.
FIVE ONE SO THE VOTE IS FIVE ONE
ON A. B. ONCE EVERY FIVE THAT
THAT BILL IS OUT. EIGHTY FOUR
THIRTY NINE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE FLOOR.
CARE VOTES HI.
BEL.
BELL I JACKSON.
JACKSON I PAN HI CAN I THAT IS
THAT IS AN EIGHTY FOUR THIRTY
NINE AND FIVE EIGHTHS.
SIX ZERO THE VOTE FOR A B. FOUR
THREE NINE IS SIX THERE ON THAT
BILL IS OUT. EIGHTY ITEM EIGHT
EIGHTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN FRASIER
THE MOTIONS THE PAST TWO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE THE
TERRIBLE HI.
BILL.
BELL I JACKSON.
JACKSON HI THE SIX SIX ZERO THE
BOAT IS SIX ZERO AND THAT BILL
IS OUT. EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHTEEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EIGHT MEN THE
MOTION IS DO YOU PASS TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
BELL.
BELL HI THAT HAS SIX PHONES.
THIRD THE BOAT IS SIX ZERO AND
THAT BILL IS OUT.
ITEM -- TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT ZERO
SEVEN POWER CAN CAN.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE --
THE TERRIBLE TIE BELL.
BELL I PAN OR EXCUSE ME WINNER.
WINNER I SIX THE BO IS SIX ZERO
AND THAT BILL IS OUT.
ITEM FOURTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTY
ONE SOMEONE MEMBER TENDS THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
CHAIR VOTES I BELL [inaudible]
VOTING [inaudible]
AND CAN [inaudible]
HI.
IT HAS FOUR VOTES.
YES OKAY YEAH THE BILL IS.
IS OUT ON A BOAT.
FOUR ZERO ITEM FIFTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT SIXTY FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RADIUS THE MOTION IS DO YOU PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CHAIR VOTES HI.
JACKSON.
JACKSON I HAVE SIX BULBS.
THE VOTE TO SIX THERE THAT BILL
IS OUT [inaudible]
IN.
ITEM SEVENTEEN ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WICKS -- THE MOTION -- AT.
TEN TWENTY TWO THE MOTION IS D.
PASSES A MINUTE TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMEMORATION
COMMITTEE CHAIR BOATS.
TERRIBLE HI.
I'M SORRY IF SOMEONE'S OUT AT
ALL RIGHT TO CONSUME.
CALENDAR.
SO ITEMS.
FOUR SIX SEVEN IN NINETEEN
RECOMMENDED TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR [inaudible]
TERRIBLE I BELL [inaudible]
HI.
SIX SOMEONE OR WHAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR PATIENCE -- AND
JUST.
TO ADD THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
SIX SIX ZERO SO THAT -- THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR PATIENCE
AND WERE TAKING UP ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY ONE NOW CRAZY TWELVE
TWENTY NINE THEY GO FREE TO
PRESENT WHEN YOU'RE READY AND
WITNESSES HALF AT THREE MINUTES
GREAT.
THANK PERFECT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE AGAIN FOR THEIR WORK
AND WILL ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TODAY.
MANY OF OUR USE INSPIRED A
HIGHER EDUCATION BUT THE SAD
REALITY IS ONLY 4324% OF FOSTER
YOUTH EARNED A BACHELOR'S DEGREE
IN LESS THAN LESS THAN 1% WILL
OBTAIN A MASTER'S OR DOCTORATE.
AND A SIGNIFICANT FACTOR AS TO
WHY THERE'S THESE LOWER.
HIGHER EDUCATION PAYMENT FOR
FOSTER YOUTH IS A LACK OF
FINANCIAL STABILITY ANOTHER
SUPPORTS THE MORE TRADITIONAL
SERVICES AS TRADITIONAL STUDENTS
RECEIVE.
MY BILL AB TWELVE TWENTY NINE
ONES FOR THE FOSTER USE HAVE THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO BE FOOD
SECURE.
AND PURSUE WORK OPPORTUNITIES IN
HIGHER EDUCATION BY DOING TWO
THINGS ONE PROVIDING
SUPPLEMENTAL BENEFITS IN THE
FORM OF CALIFORNIA.
AND TO EXPANDING THE TYPES OF
OURS ALLOWABLE FOR FOSTER USED
TO QUALIFY FOR CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND IT DOES I THINK CONTINUES IN
THE THEME OF THE BILL THAT IJUST PRESENTED AS WELL -- AND
THAT I BELIEVE THAT -- ACCESS TO
FOOD IS ONE OF THE MOST BASIC
HUMAN RIGHTS -- AND THAT WE NEED
TO SUPPORT -- ARE MORE
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS TO ENSURE
THEY HAVE THE FOOD THAT THEY
NEED -- I WANT TO THANK OUR
SPONSORS THE WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY AND JOURNEY
HOUSE I WILL LET MY WITNESSES
SELF INTRODUCED I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN I BO TODAY.
A GOOD AFTERNOON -- CHAIRMAN WAS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
JESSE AGUILAR AND I AM HERE ON
BEHALF OF JOURNEY HOUSE.
AS A CO SPONSORS OF A B. --
TWELVE TWENTY NINE WE HAVE
WORKED -- WITH A FORM OF FARSI
THING LOS ANGELES FOR OVER
THIRTY FIVE YEARS OF IN THEM IN
THE CHURCH EDUCATION.
ARM AND WE OFTEN FIND OURSELVES
HAVING TO HELP THEM NAVIGATE
DIFFERENT RESOURCES.
THAT THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THEM IN THEIR
EDUCATIONAL JOURNEYS -- INTO
OFTEN WE SEE OUR STUDENTS.
YOU KNOW HAVING TO MAKE OF IT
THE DIFFICULT DECISIONS OF
DETERMINING WHAT PRIORITY
THEY'RE GOING.
TO ADDRESS WHETHER THEY'RE GOING.
TO KEEP A ROOF OVER THEIR HEADS
OR WHETHER THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE
FOOD IN THEIR STOMACHS -- AND SO
WE HEAR TODAY IN A STRONG
SUPPORT OF A B. -- TWELVE TWENTY
NINE BECAUSE WE SEE THAT A LOT
OF THE STUDENTS THAT WEWORK
WITH.
A DRUG CASE MANAGEMENT PROGRAM --
ARE OFTEN FINDING THEMSELVES.
OF FOOD IN SECURE -- AND SO THAT
IS WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY TO ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS A
COMMITTEE TO ASK ABOUT THE
WESTERN SURINAME POVERTY WE ARE
A SPONSOR AND SUPPORT -- DR
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
PLEASE COME UP AND STATE YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION.
AT THE CENTER OF THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT.
SHOP THE FOR SIDE WITH ALAMEDA
COUNTY COMMUNITY FOOD BANK AND
SUPPORT.
HIMMLER'S REPRESENTING A SPEAR
AND THAT AND SUPPORT.
CHECK OF REAGAN NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORK TELL
FRENCH OPEN STRONG SUPPORT.
KRISTIN PARALYZE JONES WRITES IN
SUPPORT.
MAR THE GRILL REPRESENTED LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT.
DANIEL MALLOY CALIFORNIA LINES
OF CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR SOME OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS AND SUPPORT.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL.
NO DO YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
WHICH AS A MEMBER WITH WHICH
LIKE TO CLOSE THIS RESPECT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE
ALRIGHT SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR STONE AND THE MOTION IS
TO DO PASS AS AMENDED DESCENDED
EDUCATION SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL -- TITLE I TITLE HI
STONE STONE HI BELL.
BELL I JACKSON.
PAN RIGHT HAND I WINNER.
WINNER HI [inaudible]
BY.
ZERO SO THE BALL IS FIVE ZERO
AND WE WILL PUT THAT -- THAT
BILL ON CALL.
IF ANOTHER SEPARATE ABOUT THANK
YOU.
AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER WAKES YOU
HAVE ONE MORE ITEM ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY TWO A B. THIRTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON AGAIN -- MADAM CHAIR
AND SENATORS FOOD SECURITY AMONG
HOUSEHOLDS WITH SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN REMAINS HIGH.
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND TO REDUCE CHILD HUNGER THE
FREE AND REDUCED PRICE MEALS
PROGRAM HAS HELPED CHILDREN GAIN
ACCESS TO ADEQUATE FOOD AND IS
AIMED TO REDUCE FOOD AND
SECURITIES.
AND PROMOTE HEALTHY DEVELOPMENT
WHICH AS WE KNOW ESPECIALLY FOR
SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN IS VERY
CRITICAL TO THEIR LEARNING.
HOWEVER A SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF
FOOD IN SECURE CHILDREN ARE
RECEIVING FREE OR REDUCED MEALS
BUT THEY ARE NOT RECEIVING
BENEFITS THROUGH CAL FRESH.
AND THAT'S FUNDAMENTALLY WHAT
THIS BILL AIMS TO DO.
AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN WILL
DIRECT STATE DEPARTMENTS LOCAL
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCIES AND KEY
STAKEHOLDERS TO EXAMINE DATA AN
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS ACROSS
THE DIFFERENT BENEFITS PROGRAMS.
IN ORDER TO FIND THE BEST
POSSIBLE SOLUTION AND DEVELOP A
STATEWIDE PROCESS THAT WOULD
IMPLEMENT THE XCELERATED
ENROLLMENT OF CHILDREN INTO CAL
FRESH.
THE BILL HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
IN THE ASSEMBLY I WANT TO THANK
OUR SPONSORS THE CALIFORNIA
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
FOOD BANKS.
AND I WILL LET MY WITNESSES --
SELF INTRODUCE AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK YET AGAIN FOR
ANOTHER I VOTE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
KATHY CENTERED WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
PLEASE A CO SPONSOR OF
LEGISLATION.
THE THE ISSUE AS WE KNOW IS THAT
CHILDREN IN POVERTY CHILDREN HER
HUNGRY AND THE TOXIC STRESS THAT
THAT BRINGS MAKE THEM UNABLE TO
LEARN EFFECTIVELY ESPECIALLY
COMPARED TO THEIR PEERS.
IT SETS THEM BACK AND THERE HAVE
BEEN ONGOING DISCUSSIONS OVER
THE TWENTY YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN
IN THIS JOB ABOUT HOW TO IMPROVE
CONFERENCE PARTICIPATION FOR
THOSE CHILDREN AND THEIR
FAMILIES WERE NOT INVOLVED.
WE FEEL LIKE THE SCHOOL LUNCH
PROGRAM SHOULD HAVE AN AVENUE
FOR THAT WE FEEL LIKE PERHAPS
USING MEDICAL DATA WOULD HAVE AN
AVENUE FOR THAT BUT THE RULES
ARE DIFFERENT ACROSS THE THREE
PROGRAMS.
THEY HAVE DIFFERENT DATA SYSTEMS
AND SO WE DO NEED TO FIGURE OUT
A WAY TO TRY TO MATCH ALL OF
THAT UP TO FIGURE OUT WHAT IS
OUR UNIVERSE THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE AND HOW DO WE GET AT
THAT UNIVERSE TO REDUCE AND
BRING AS MANY OF THE CHILDREN.
AND THEIR FAMILIES INTO THE
PROGRAM AS WELL THERE'S A LOT OF
ISSUES RIGHT NOW OF COURSE WITH
IMMIGRANTS AND IMMIGRATION THERE --
EFFORTS WE DON'T WANT TO PRESUME
THE ANSWER TO THIS QUESTION BUT
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE
SEEN IS THAT LEGISLATION THAT WE
THOUGHT SPONSORED OURSELVES IN
SOME CASES JUST HAVEN'T GOT IT
DONE.
WE FEEL LIKE BRINGING EVERYBODY
TO THE TABLE AND HAVING THE
LEGISLATURE STAY THIS IS
IMPORTANT FORMALLY WE WANT YOU
AT THIS TABLE TO FIGURE THIS OUT
WILL HELP US CRACK THAT NOT
THAT'S WHAT THE IDEA.
DYLAN WE ARE DRIVER.
THANK YOU YOUR SON OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS -- AS YOU HEARD WE KNOW
THAT HOW FRESH IS A REALLY
CRITICAL SAFETY NET AND WE SEE
THAT FOR LOW INCOME FAMILIES
THAT DO HAVE ACCESS TO CAL FOR
ASH.
THEIR HEALTHCARE COSTS ARE
LOWERED THEY HAVE HIGHER
LIKELIHOOD OF I'M GRADUATING
FROM HIGH SCHOOL AND THEY LOWER
THEIR RISK OF HEART DISEASE
AMONG MANY OTHER FACTORS -- THAT
IMPROVE THEIR LIVES AND WE ALSO
KNOW THAT THE ENROLLMENT RATING
HOW FRESH IS TOO LOW AND THAT
MANY MANY HOUSEHOLD INCLUDING
CHILDREN WHO ARE ACTUALLY
ELIGIBLE NOT.
AND ARE NOT GETTING THE ACCESS
THAT THEY DESERVE TO THE PROGRAM.
I'M.
LIKE YOU HEARD MANY COUNTIES
HAVE TRIED -- TO FIGURE OUT A
GOOD CONNECTION BETWEEN SCHOOL
MEALS AND CAL FOR US AND IT'S
BEEN.
INCREDIBLY CUMBERSOME AND REALLY
COMPLICATED AND DIFFICULT TO
FIGURE OUT THE RIGHT WAY TO DO
IT.
I AM SO WE A ALONG WITH -- THE
DEBT THE DEPARTMENTS AND MANY
OTHER ADVOCATES ARE REALLY%
LOOKING FORWARD TO A FORMAL
PROCESS TO TRYIN.
I'M FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO THIS
WELL IN A WAY THAT MAKES ACCESS
TO CAL FRESH AND DIGNIFIED
INEFFICIENT AND ALSO CREATES A
STREAMLINED AND REALLY SIMPLE
PROCESS FOR BOTH COUNTIES AND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO MAKE IT
HAPPEN SO.
ON THIS ON THIS BILL.
DOES HAVE A BI PARTISAN SUPPORT
AND AT THIS TIME WILL TAKE ANY
WITNESSES THAT ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
LIKE HE DOES HE'LL BE HAVE THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO
AND SUPPORT.
DOES PARCLO WESTERNS AND OUR LAN
PARTY IN SPORT.
KELLY BROOKS HERE IN SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF THE VENTURA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
THE GROUP REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT.
SHANTI PRASAD ALAMEDA COUNTY
COMMUNITY FOOD BANK AND SUPPORT.
THE FREIGHTER NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORK
CONFERENCE CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
DO YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL. THREE NINE
OKAY DO HAVE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS CONVINCED CENTER
PLANNED -- SO QUICK QUESTION --
KELSO'S INTEGRATION IS THAT
GOING TO HELP WITH THE THIS.
I THINK IT CAN ONLY HELP A YEAH
OF MY CO SPONSOR IS -- A GREEN
WIND THAT SO WE HAVE THE SAME
WAY DATA SYSTEM THERE STILL ARE
THREE SYSTEMS THAT MAKE UP THE
STATEWIDE DATA SYSTEM SOMEONE'S
WE HAVE THAT ALL IN ONE PLACE
OKAY IT CERTAINLY SHOULD BE
EASIER WE THINK BOTH THE FIGURE
OUT THE SCOPE OF THE ISSUE.
AND THEN THINK ABOUT WAYS TO
MATCH OF DATA TO BE ABLE TO OKAY
AS AVI SURE THAT AS WE'RE
INTEGRATING SYSTEMS THIS IS
GONNA BUILT AND SO OKAY THANK
YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY AS A MEMBER WITH WHICH IT
WHAT'S BEEN SELECTED CLOSEST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I GOT.
OKAY THANK YOU -- SO WE DO HAVE
A MOTION BY CENTER STONE THE
MOTION IS TO DO PASSED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS AS SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL A TITLE I
TITLE I STONE.
STONE HI BEL.
WINNER WINNER HI.
THE DEVIL IS FIVE ZERO MOLD BUT
THAT BILL ON THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SO UP NEXT WE HAVE -- AGENDA
ITEM EIGHTEEN A. B. TEN SIXTY
EIGHT AND THEY'RE AFTER AGENDA
ITEM.
I NEED THREE WE HAVE ASSEMBLY --
NUMBER REVERSE THAT --
THEREAFTER.
THE WELCOME.
HELLO.
WHEN THEY PUT?
SO THIS BILL DOES HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT -- YOU'RE
DOING YOUR WITNESSES HAVE THREE
MINUTES TO PRESENT PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
ROSE AND WHICH ROOM WITH YOU --
I'M HERE TODAY TO PRESENT A BE.
TEN SIXTY EIGHT OF RELATED TO
CHILD AND FAMILY TEAMS IN THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
OF THE SYSTEM IS OFTEN WORKED
AND HOW DO YOU BRING TOGETHER
VARIOUS PROFESSIONALS TO SUPPORT
CHILDREN [inaudible]
ON THESE TEAMS BRING TOGETHER
CHARACTER OF THE CHILD CHILD
WILL FOR AGING IN ONE ELSE.
NEEDED FOR SUPPORT. TO HELP IN
THESE PLACEMENTS -- THIS BILL
STREET IN THE CITY PROCESS BY
CREATED NOTICE REQUIREMENTS.
ENGAGE NEUTRAL FACILITATE
FACILITATORS.
ENSURES EDUCATIONAL RIGHTS
HOLDER IS INCLUDED DECISION.
I'M DELIGHTED TO HAVE SUPPORT
TODAY FROM.
CURRENT MAKE SURE I GET THIS
RIGHT -- STEVE ASHMAN WITH THE
SENSOR COUNTY CASA PROGRAM.
AND I'M GONNA TURN TO STEVEN MY
OTHER WITNESSES BECAUSE FOR THE
BILL.
GREAT THANK YOU I'LL BE
EXTREMELY BRIEF GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS SEAN C. AS YOU AND I
WORK WITH THE ALLIANCE FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS AND WE ARE
VERY HONORED TO BE CO SPONSORS
OF A V..
TEN SIXTY EIGHT JOHN FAMILY
TEAMS ARE A KEY COMPONENT OF THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE REFORM THEY
GIVE THE YOUTH CARE GIVERS AND
FAMILIES A VOICE IN THE DECISION
MAKING AND SERVICE PLANNING THAT
IMPACTS OUR LIVES.
HOWEVER THAT ONLY WORKS WHEN
FAMILIES HAVE ADVANCE NOTICE OF
TEAM MEETINGS WHEN THE RIGHT
PEOPLE ARE INCLUDED IN THE
DISCUSSIONS.
I WENT ITEMS AGREED TO BY THE
TEAM OR FOLLOW UP ON AND ACTED
UPON SO THIS BILL WILL ENSURE
THAT THOSE THINGS HAPPEN.
AND STEVE AUSTIN IS HERE TO
SPEAK FROM PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
THE IMPORTANCE OF THESE
PROVISIONS THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND I STRONGLY URGE RIVAL.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- MY NAME'S
STEVE ASHTON I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE COURT APPOINTED
SPECIAL ADVOCATES PROGRAM IN
STANISLAUS COUNTY -- BUT IS ALSO
BEEN MY PRIVILEGE OVER THE LAST
ELEVEN YEARS TO BE AN ADVOCATE --
FOR THE CHILDREN OF OUR COUNTY.
IN THAT ELEVEN YEARS -- I HAVE
HELD EDUCATION RIGHTS FOR A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
DIFFERENT CHILDREN.
CURRENTLY I HOLD EDUCATION
RIGHTS FOR THIRTY SIX DIFFERENT
CHILDREN AND YOUTH -- I A I'M
SOMETIMES INCLUDED IN CHILD
FAMILY TEAM MEETINGS BUT OFTEN
WHEN I AM I'M NOTICED --
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN ONE HOUR AND
TWO DAYS AHEAD OF TIME -- NOT
NEARLY ENOUGH TIME TO PREPARE
AND OR EVEN SHOW UP TO A MEETING
THAT IS OFTEN VERY VERY
IMPORTANT.
BECAUSE ALL OF THE KIDS THAT I
ADVOCATE FOR AND HOLD AT RICE
FOR HOUSE SOME SIGNIFICANT
EDUCATIONAL OR MENTAL HEALTH OR
CUT SOME COMBINATION OF NEED.
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE
DISCUSS THEIR EDUCATIONAL
OUTCOMES FOR THE PROBABLE ONES
WHEN THEY'RE MOVED.
RECENTLY IN FEBRUARY I HAD A
YOUNG MAN WHO'S FOURTEEN YEARS
OLD WHO IS FOUR MONTHS AWAY FROM
GRADUATING FROM MIDDLE SCHOOL
AND MOVING ON TO HIGH SCHOOL.
HE WAS ATTENDING A NON PUBLIC
SCHOOL IN OUR COUNTY -- AND
CHILD WELFARE DECIDED THAT THEY
NEEDED TO MOVE HIM AND IN THEIR
INFINITE WISDOM THEY MOVED HIM
ABOUT EIGHTY MILES AWAY FROM HIS
CURRENT SCHOOL.
THEY MOVED HIM TO A COUNTY WHERE
THERE WERE NO SERVICES
WHATSOEVER TO MEET IS
EDUCATIONAL MENTAL HEALTH OR
OTHER NEEDS.
HAD THEY INCLUDED ME IN THE
MEETINGS THAT THEY WERE HOLDING
TO DISCUSS THE SITUATION FOR
THIS YOUNG MAN.
THEY WOULD HAVE KNOWN THAT THE
SERVICES -- IN THE COUNTY THEY
WERE MOVING HIM TO WERE
BASICALLY NONEXISTENT.
AS A RESULT -- BECAUSE I HELD
HIS HEAD RIGHTS AND I HAVE THE
RIGHT TO KEEP HIM IN A SCHOOL OF
ORIGIN THANKS TO PREVIOUS
LEGISLATION -- WE WORKED OUT A
WAY TO KEEP HIM IN A SCHOOL
UNTIL THE END OF THE SEMESTER --
HOWEVER ALL A LOT OF ISSUES
COULD HAVE BEEN AVOIDED NOT NOT.
THE LEAST OF WHICH WERE SOME OF
THE STRESSORS THAT WERE PLACED
UPON THIS YOUNG MAN KNOWING THAT
HE WAS MOVING AND THE FEAR THAT
HE WAS GOING TO BE LEAVING A
SCHOOL THAT HE HAD BEEN OUT FOR
THE PREVIOUS FIVE YEARS -- AB
ONE TEN SIXTY EIGHT WILL ENSURE
THAT RIGHTS HOLDERS ARE SITTING
AT THE TABLE.
IT ALSO WOULD ASSURE INSURES
THAT THERE IS SUCH A PROPER
NOTICE GIVEN TO US SO THAT WE
CAN MEANINGFULLY PARTICIPATE IN
ANY AND ALL MEETINGS.
WHICH IS A NECESSITY.
AND LASTLY -- ONE OF THE THINGS
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT IS THE
ACCOUNTABILITY TO THE COURT.
OUR JUDGE IN OUR COUNTY WANTS TO
KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON IN EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF HER CASES AND ALSO
WANTS TO KNOW VERY SPECIFICALLY
WHAT'S GOING ON IN TERMS OF
EDUCATION.
I THINK THAT.
NOTICE OF A CFT MEETING AND WHAT
HAPPENS IN WHO ATTENDS THOSE
MEETINGS IS IMPORTANT TO INCLUDE
IN THOSE COURT REPORTS SO I
RESPECTIVE RESPECTIVELY REQUEST
YOUR I VOTE ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU STEVE.
THANK YOU HOW DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
GOOD EVENING DANIEL MALL A
CALIFORNIA LIGHTS OF CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES AND SUPPORT.
JULIE MCCORMICK CHILDREN'S LAW
CENTER CALIFORNIA -- CO SPONSOR
AND STRONG SUPPORT.
CHRISTINA PARK TO A CALIFORNIA
CONNECTION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN OF
ACTUALLY THE NEBULOUS THIRD
CATEGORY OF WORKING TOWARD
SUPPORT AND HAVE AN ENGAGING
CADDIES AND KNOWING WHAT THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS.
ASSOCIATION WITH THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS FOR A NUMBER OF MONTHS
NOW AND WE'RE GETTING THERE
WE'VE -- WRKED OUT OUT A LOT OF
AMENDMENTS THE MAJOR I THINK
AREA THAT WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE WORKING ON AND HAVE NO
ISSUES AT THE BILL MOVING
FORWARD TO JUDICIARY.
IS RELATED TO THE FACILITATION
THE IDEA OF HAVING A THIRD PARTY
FACILITATOR WHO'S NEUTRAL IS NOT
AND AFTER MY IT IS NOT A
TERRIBLE IDEA HOWEVER THE CAT
APPROACH TO THE BILL TAKES WE'RE
CONCERNED.
TIPS TOO MUCH IN FAVOR OF ALWAYS
HAVING THAT PERSON DO THAT
FACILITATION AND WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS WORK WITH AUTHOR
AND SPONSORS TO GET AT THE IDEA
THAT THE YOUTH THEMSELVES.
COULD ACTUALLY BE THE
FACILITATOR WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK ON IT I JUST WANT TO SHARE
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT OUR OUR
ONGOING CONCERNS BUT WE'RE
WORKING THROUGH IT THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE ANY -- WITNESS AS
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
WITH THE ALL RIGHT I DO HAVE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
NO OKAY A WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
HONOR TO BE HERE A QUESTION I
WILL THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
OKAY SO WE HAVE A EMOTION TO TO
PASS THE SENATE DID THE TREE BY
SENATOR STONE AND SECRETARY CAN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
RICARDO HI RICARDO HI.
STEM RIGHT STONE I BELL RIGHT
BELL HI JACKSON PAN.
PAN I WINNER.
WINNER HI.
THE VOTE IS FIVE ZERO AND WE
WILL PUT THAT BILL ON CALL TO
ALLOW OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO
VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND UP NEXT WE HAVE A FAMILY
MEMBER [inaudible]
REVERSE.
PRESENTING HERE ON A BC.
ONE SEVEN ZERO TWO THIS BILL.
HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- TODAY I'M PROUD TO
PRESENT A B. SEVENTEEN OH TWO
WHICH REQUIRES ADDITIONAL
STAFFING RESOURCES FOR THE
HOMELESS COORDINATING AND
FINANCING COUNCIL.
AND ADDS NEW REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS TO THE COUNCIL --
FROM TWENTY SIXTEEN TO TWENTY
SEVENTEEN CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCE
THE LARGEST INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF RESIDENTS EXPERIENCE
HOMELESS SAYS HOMELESSNESS -- IN.
ALSO IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY AUTHORED BY
SENATOR HOLLY MITCHELL CREATED
THE COUNCIL. TO OVERSEE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF HOUSING FIRST
GUIDELINES AND TO IDENTIFY IN
COURT DATE STATE RESOURCES AND
SERVICES TO PREVENT AND END
HOMELESSNESS ISN'T IN CALIFORNIA --
WHILE LAST YEAR'S BUDGET BILL TO
PROVIDE THREE PERMANENT STAFF TO
THE COUNCIL I'M WE'RE HEARING
FROM THE COUNCIL THAT THEY'RE
CURRENTLY SHORT STAFFED.
AB SEVENTEEN OH TWO TAKES THREE
EXISTING PART TIME POSITIONS AT
THE COUNCIL AND MAKES THOSE FULL
TIME POSITIONS AND ADDS AN
ADDITIONAL THREE POSITIONS TO
THE COUNCIL -- TO IMPLEMENT ITS
LEGISLATIVELY MANDATED DUTIES TO
COMBAT HOMELESSNESS.
I'M HAPPY TO HAVE WITH ME TODAY
CHRIS MARTIN WITH HOUSING
CALIFORNIA TO SUPPORT A B..
SEVENTEEN OH TWO THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CHRIS MARTIN WITH HOUSING
CALIFORNIA.
HERE SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB --
SEVENTEEN OH TWO AS A MEMBER
MENTIONED -- HOMES CORNING
FINANCING COUNCIL WAS CREATED --
THROUGH SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY TO
IMPLEMENT -- HOUSING FIRST THAT
OUR STATE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS -- AND IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WITH THE BUDGET --
PASSING THE ACCOUNTS WAS GIVEN
THREE STAFF AS WELL AS A FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR PROGRAM
TO IMPLEMENT -- AND AS A RESULT
OF THAT -- THEY THEY HAVE BEEN.
HANDLING A LOT THAT THE CORN IN
COUNCIL AND THIS PAST YEAR THEY
RELEASED THEIR ACTION PLAN FOR
THIS COMING YEAR -- WHICH
INCLUDED SEVEN ITEMS AND OF
WHICH IS CONTINUING TO
ADMINISTER THAT ALMOST EMERGENCY
AID PROGRAM -- CREATING A STATE
LEVEL HOMELESS INTEGRATED DATA
SYSTEM AS WELL AS A STRATEGIC
PLAN AMONG OTHER THINGS -- AND
SO AS YOU CAN IMAGINE -- THE THE
COUNCIL IS BUSY WITH QUITE A BIT
OF WORK THIS YEAR AND HAS AN
AMBITIOUS -- SLADE AHEAD OF THEM
AND SO -- THAT WE BELIEVE THEY
NEED -- ADEQUATE CAPACITY AND
STAFF TO HANDLE THAT --
AGGRESSIVE AGENDA -- AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR EYES
THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE.
THANK YOU -- DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
I'M GOOD AT THE NUMARK THE
GUERRERO REPRESENTED LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
IN SUPPORT.
KILLERS ARE PRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOUTH
AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVEN'T ANY
WITNESSES OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
NOW DO WE HAVE ANY.
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR RIVAL.
OKAY THANK YOU ARE SO WE HAVE A
MOTION VICE BUT SENATOR STONE
AND THE MOTION IS TO DO PASSED
SENATE HOUSING.
A SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
RIHANNA I FOR TITLE I STONE
STONE HI BEL.
BELL I JACKSON.
AND I AM I WINNER WINNER HI.
THE DEVIL IS FIVE ZERO WE PULL
UP PLACES BUILT ON CALL TO ALLOW
OTHERS GIVING HERO.
THANK YOU AND UP NEXT WE HAVE
AGENDA ITEM.
TWENTY AB ONE TWO TWO SEVEN THIS
BILL DOES HAVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE IN TWO THOUSAND
SIX A STATE LAW WAS AMENDED TO
ALLOW INFORMATION SHARING
BETWEEN AGENCIES WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
THE INFORMATION TO BE SHARED OUR
ADMINISTRATIVE ACTIONS THAT
MIGHT BE TAKEN AGAINST A LICENSE
THAT.
COULD POSSIBLY HOLD LICENSES
UNDER DIFFERENT AGENCIES.
ARE IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
THE CALIFORNIA TATE AUDITOR
ISSUED AN AUDIT IN WHICH THEY
FOUND THAT EVEN THOUGH STATE LAW
ALLOW THAT INFORMATION SHARING
QUITE OFTEN IT WAS NOT OCCURRING.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE THAT
INFORMATION SHARING TO OCCUR
BETWEEN THESE AGENCIES
IMPLEMENTING THE AUDITORS
RECOMMENDATION.
THIS WOULD HELP THESE AGENCIES
PROTECT THE VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS THAT THEY ARE
RESPONSIBLE.
FOR DANIEL SABINO SUBSTATION OF
REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES THE
REGIONAL CENTERS TO AMONG OTHER
THINGS.
OVERSIGHT AND QUALITY ASSURANCE
FOR PROVIDERS OF CARE FOR PEOPLE
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
KNOWING THIS INFORMATION IS A
REALLY GREAT WAY TO HELP GET IN
FRONT OF ISSUES BEFORE THEY CROP
UP.
JUST BECAUSE INFORMATION CAN BE
SURE DOESN'T MEAN IT IS AND THIS
IS WHY WE ARE -- AND CONTINUE TO
BE IN SUPPORT.
SO MUCH I DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE
SPELL.
ANY WITNESSES OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL THE NON OKAY TO HAVE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS NOW.
OKAY SO WE HAVE A MOTION --
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE JUST
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN IPHONE
OKAY GREAT THE MOTION.
PASSED TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
BY CENTER STONE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL RIHANNA.
I TITLE I STONE.
STONE I'D DOWN.
BELL I JACKSON.
FAN ALL RIGHT AND I WINNER
WINNER HIGH FIVES.
SO THE BOAT IS -- FIVE ZERO WE
WILL PLACE THAT BILL ON CALL A
TO ALLOW OTHERS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ENTER BUT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
SIR SENATOR JACKSON IS SOMEWHERE
SO SHE'S ON A CALL.
ADDITIONAL.
WITH -- EIGHTEEN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND TWENTY THREE OKAY
SO AT THIS POINT WE ARE -- WE
WILL BE TAKING UP AND BE ON CALL
BILLS ONCE WE GET SENATOR
JACKSON.
TOO COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME HERE
TODAY.
AND WE ARE GOING.
TO STAY PUT FOR AWHILE
[inaudible]
YEAH ABSOLUTELY.
I WASN'T SURE HOW MUCH IT
OVERLAPS THE ORGANIZATION OF THE
GENERAL IDEA IS GOOD NO
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
OUR OKAY.
AND SO AT THIS POINT WE ARE
GOING.
TO I TURNED IT ON THAT'S OKAY.
SO AT THIS POINT -- WE ARE GOING
TO TAKE UP ITEMS THAT ARE ON
CALL.
SO SECRETARY CAN YOU -- CAN YOU
OPEN UP THE ROLL CALL FOR ON
CALL ITEMS.
ITEM EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TEN SIXTY
EIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOLLY THE
MOTION IS DO YOU PASS TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE THE CHAIR
BOTH SIDES JACKSON [inaudible]
HI.
AND SO THEY ARE.
A JACKSON I SIX SIX ZERO THE
VOTE.
THE VOTE IS SIX ZERO AND THE
BILL IS OUT ITEM TWENTY A.. TWO
TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN OVER NOLTE.
THE I. THE MOTION IS D. PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE THE
CHAIR BOWTIE JACKSON.
JACKSON HI.
SIX THE BO IS SIX ZERO IN THAT
BILL IS OUT.
ITEM TWENTY ONE EIGHTY TWELVE
TWENTY NINE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WICKS THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE.
JACKSON HI JACKSON HI.
HI.
SIX THE DEVIL IS SIX ZERO AND
THAT BILL IS OUT.
ITEM TWENTY TWO A. B. --
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN ESTIMATE
MEMBER WICKS THE MOTION IS DO
YOU PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CHAIR BOWTIE JACKSON
HI JACKSON HI.
THE VOTE IS SIX ZERO IN THAT
BILL ITSELF ITEM TWENTY THREE AB
SEVENTEEN OH TWO ASSEMBLYMEMBER
REVERSE THE MOTION IS DO YOU
PASS TO THE HOUSING COMMITTEE.
CHAIR VOTES BY JACKSON.
JACKSON HI. SIX ZERO SIX THERE
ON THAT BILL IS OUT.
AND THAT IN OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING FOR TODAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR JOINING US.
AND WE ARE JOINED